なんとか役に立つようにお話をしますけど
あまり今はもう育児は関係ないという方々にとっては
それなりに役に立つように
一般的な人間論として
両方まとめてしゃべりますので
どなたにでも役に立てばありがたいことで
一番最初に言いたいことは
この我々 この人間にとって
ちょっとした誤解があるんですね
ちょっとした誤解がありまして
人間というのは
よく勉強できて ものすごく頭が良くて
それからすごいお金持ちで有名になって
という目的が人生の目的だと
そういうふうに思っているんです
あまり子供のこと気にしないで話を聞いてください
で ちょっと真剣に聞かないと
すごいきめ細かいポイントなんですから
すぐ頭から滑る可能性あります
これ一番最初に言うこのポイントはとても大事なんです
人間はどのように大きくなればいいかということ
そこら辺で我々は最初からもう
直さなくちゃいけないことがあるんですね
普通の世の中では ものすごい金持ちだったらありがたいと
すごい有名な人だったら
これほどありがたいことはないんだと
ものすごい頭のいい人だったら
これまたすごいありがたいと
そういうふうな考え方を持ってるんですね
それからこの 女性の場合はね
立派なところにお嫁に行けば
これはこれこそありがたいことだと
そういう目的があって
我々は育児に手を出しているんです
だから どんな母親でも
自分の子供を成長させて一人前にしたい
という気持ちはもう誰でも同じだと思います
そこで問題はこの成長した一人前の人間
というのは何なのかということなんです
成功した人間って何なのかと
それで親の心の中でなんとなく尺度というか
いくらかのイメージができちゃうんですね
そのイメージ自体がすごく曖昧で
親に聞いても あなたの子供はどういうふうに大人になればいいかと
はっきりわからないでしょ
ほとんどわかってないんです
どういうふうな人間になった方が良いかと
大体赤ちゃんの時だけこう言うんですね
元気で明るくて それなりに大きくなればいいやとかね
自由に好きなように この子はもう好きなように育ててあげるぞと
とは 小さい時 なぜあんなことを言うんですか？自分で歩くことさえもできませんからね
子供には 何もできない時はそう言うんだけど
どんどんまた考え方がグルグルグル変わっちゃうんですね
グルグル変わっちゃう
そこでお隣に付き合ってるお母さんが
なんとか学校の方があれはすごい良い学校だと思ったら
やっぱり自分の子もその学校に入れたくなっちゃうんですね
私だったらもうなんとか店でしか私の子供に服を買えませんと言ったならば
自分もまたその店に行ってその服を買いたくなる
そうやって うちの子はすごいピアノ上手ですねと
もう3歳からもう弾き始めたんだよって言ったら
やっぱりうちの子もピアノ習った方がいいんじゃないかなと
そうやっていい加減なことばっかり考えてるんですね
そんな親が1日4回ぐらい人生の目的が変わっちゃうと子供はどうですかね
その被害者が だって全部子供にさせるものだから
この被害者たちのこともちょっと考えた方がいいんじゃないかなと思いますね
ですから この話が始まる前に
我々は一番最初に考えなくてはいけないことは
成功した人生って何なのかということなんです
そこは最初から決めて
そこから離れないならば
脱出しないならば 子供にもわかるんですね
私はこの道を歩めばいいんだと
これ  1日 4回ぐらい人生の目的が変わると
朝は音楽家になり ピアニストになりなさいと言って
もう 6時になってくると
いえ 画家の方がいいんですよと言っちゃうと
どうにもならなくなっちゃうんですね
それでまず成功した人生って何なのかということを説明します
これ考えてみてください
もし自分の子供がオリンピックで金メダルを取ったりする
すごいありがたいことでしょう
楽しくてたまらない でも金メダルを取ったのはいいんだけど
それなりにお金も入って豊かになるのかもしれませんけど
有名にもなるかもしれませんけど
その人にはもしその人気のある子の生き方
それに対応できなくて
朝から晩まで忙しくて
あっち呼ばれるわ こっち呼ばれるわ
そこで日本人 国民みんなとんでもない希望をつけておくわ
今度のオリンピックでも金メダルを取ってくださいとかね
そうするとものすごいきつい
何て言いますか 訓練したりとかね
朝から晩までコーチに怒鳴られて
怒られてとかね で いろんなことをあっち行って練習するわ
こっち行って練習するわ
いろんな外国に行って練習するわとかね
1年一回でも 30 分ぐらいしか母にも親にも会えないとかね
そういう状態には必ずなる
そういうなった人が その人生になかなか対応できなくて
どんどん堕落するとするならば
例えばこそこそと麻薬に手を出す
あまりにも希望をつけてしまったんだから
体力を作るためのいろんなアストロイドというんですか
ステロイドですね
そういう薬にまで手を出したりする
例えば 体がものすごい激痛するのに
いろんな鎮静剤やいろんな薬を飲みながら訓練したりする
それで人生は台無しになると
それで母親は父親には自分の子供のことを正直に喜べますかね
いくら人生台無しになっても
うちの子はオリンピック金メダル取ったんだから
それだけで十分だと言えますかね
いくら人生めちゃくちゃになったとしても
それはそれで構いませんと
言えますかね すぐ最近
なんか女優さんの方がね
の息子がね  2回目もまた麻薬使って捕まったという話
ニュースで聞いて
それでもその母親から言えますかね
やっぱり それでも私は大変人気のある一流の
タレントさんだから 芸術家だから
女優さんだからいいんじゃないかと
人生は成功しているんだと
子育ては成功しているんだということは言えますかと
だから わかりやすく言えばこういうことなんですね
自分の子供が億万長者になっても
人生むちゃくちゃだったら
子供がいい加減になるわ
もう奥さんがもう家にいないわとかね
顔も会ったことはないとかね
奥さんと で もうどこにいるか
息子があまりに忙しくてわからないとかね
そういう人生っていうのは幸せかと
ですから よく覚えてほしいのは
仏教はただ金持ちになったんだからありがたいと
頭が良くてえらくもうえらい学者になりましたと
だからそれで十分だということは絶対認めないことなんですね
時々立派な学者の方々いるんですね
朝から晩まで研究室に閉じこもられて
子供の顔さえも見たことがないと
それはちょっといい加減
余計な言い方かもしれませんけど
なかなかちょっと見るだけで
あるいは家に帰ると子供は寝ている
また家出ている まだ子供は寝ている
そういうことで 子供の顔でも見ないで
自分が仕事ばっかりやっていて
そういうことっていうのは人生だと言えますかね
だから この世の中にある価値観
全部捨てない限りは この問題は解決しないんですね
どうやって捨てるかというと
まず人間で生まれたんだから
楽に楽しく すごく幸福感を感じながら生きることこそが大事なんです
なんとかして生きてるんだっていうことは大したことじゃないんです
研究室からもうなかなかもう 2時間30分しかもう外へ出られないんだと
1年中 1日しか休みがないんだという人生は人生じゃないんです
自分の息子が総理大臣になったら
それはありがたいやと
総理大臣になったとしても
もう 1日 30分も寝る暇がもう 3時間も寝る暇がないとかね
それでストレス溜まって病気になっても
もう心臓発作じゃなくて
脳麻痺もうあれなんて言いますか
病気はもう脳出血で倒れてね
1日 2日で死んでしまっちゃうとかね
そういう人生っていうのは幸せな人生かと
ですから 一番最初にそれを覚えておいてください
やっぱり気持ちよく 楽しく
気楽に余裕があってリラックスして笑いながら
笑顔で死ぬまで生きていられることが
仏教は人間に言ってる
生きる間の目的なんです
もう一つ目的がありますけどね
一応生きている間は泣かないで
悔しがらないで生きてみなさいよと
泣きながら 神経質で震えながら
怯えながら えらい憎しみで
嫉妬で他人を憎しみながら生きていて
こんなありがたいんですかと
それはあまりにも無知的な
生き方なんですね ですから
私たち親として子供に言うべきことは
こういうことなんですよ
あなたは音楽家になろうが
学者になろうが 科学者になろうが
政治家になろうが ただのサラリーマンになろうが
勝手にしなさいよと でも
人間として豊かで 心が広くて
憎しみ 悩み 苦しみがない
落ち着いている人間になりなさいと
どんな仕事をしたとしても
そこら辺ですごく余裕があって
しっかりと自分の仕事を
果たせるような人間になりなさいと
そこが親の仕事なんですね
だから現代親たちがそれを忘れてしまっちゃって
子供を学者にしてやろうと思っちゃう
エンジニアにしてあげるぞと
医者にしてあげるぞと
そういうことをやろうとしているんですね
それはお肉屋さんに手術頼んだことと同じなんです
だってお肉屋さんもちゃんとさばいてるでしょ？動物
だからもう自分の盲腸でもなったら
もうそこら辺のお肉屋さんのところに行って
お願いします 私のこの盲腸を取ってくださいと
あんたは手慣れたものでしょうと
と頼んだらどうなるんですかね
だから大体親たちがそうやってとんでもないことを
やろうとしているんです
だから親の仕事はものすごく立派な
人間を育てていることであって
誰かこの学者とかね 政治家とか
そういうもう音楽家とか
そういう人を育てることではありません
だから親の責任がすごく多いんですよ
なぜならば 親の教育はその子が死ぬまで
死ぬまで大事なものなんですね
だから どんな親も覚えておいてほしいことは
自分が教えることが 子供にしつけすることが
その子が死ぬまで役に立つ
この子の死ぬまで役に立つものですよと
学校に行って数学を勉強したとしても
それは一時的なものなんです
たとえエンジニアになっても
60歳までもう退職するまでの仕事でしょうに
それでおじいちゃんになったところで
あんなもう工学の知識っていうのは全然役に立ちません
その時はゲートボールぐらい
習った方が役に立ちますからね
ですから この我々が希望している
狙っているというかこの人生の目的っていうのは
本当にもう意味がないんですね
全く意味がないんです
で なぜかというと このこれは仕事をしている間だけ必要なもので
それからもう役に立ちませんからね
ですから まず覚えてほしいことは
親っていうのは死ぬまで子供に必要なことを教える
先生であることなんですね
両親にお釈迦様が使っているこういう言葉があります
それは一つの言葉なんですけど
2つに分けて書いたんですけど
読み方はプッバーチャリヤ
プッバーチャリヤ その言葉はよく覚えておいてください
お釈迦様の言葉ですからね
pubbācariya
（プッバーチャリヤ）
言葉を分けて分析しちゃうと
これは言葉 2つですけど
それはpubbaという言葉と
ācariyaという言葉なんですね
pubbaというのと ācariyaという言葉は一つに書くんです
pubbācariyaという風に
でpubbaというのは最初という意味なんですね
初めという意味なんですね
ācariyaっていうのは教師のこと
教師 先生 だから 両親は誰でしょうかといえば
最初の先生 教師なんです
mātāpitaro pubbācariyāti vuccareというお釈迦様の言葉なんです
全部行全部書くと
mātāpitaro pubbācariyāti vuccare
そこでpubbācariya
最初の先生
だから自分に子供が生まれてきたら
その両親 まず考えてほしいことは
これから自分が先生になるんですね
これから 教師になるんです
それで自分が最初の教師
そこで自分が教える教えだけが死ぬまで役に立つ
学校に行ったら出会うのはもう最初の教師じゃないんです
ある専門だけ教える教師なんですね
それはもう一生役に立つということはないんです
たとえ学校で国語を勉強したとしても
年取ってからそれを忘れちゃっても
別にどうってことないんです
他の勉強なんかは忘れてももう大丈夫です
危険はないんです でも両親が教える勉強を忘れちゃったら
そこに確実に危険があるんです
そういうことで両親にどれぐらい
大変な責任があるかということは
理解していただければありがたいと思います
そこでその同じ言葉を子供に対しても言うんです
自分の両親というのは
自分の最初の先生であると
ただ何だかんだもわがまま言って
もう欲しいものは何でももう奴隷みたいに
あげる存在ではなくて
お母さんお父さんというのは先生であると
だからちょっと厳しいと
気をつけなくちゃあかんと
ということも子供は勉強しなくちゃいけない
これはとても大事な言葉なんです
そこでなぜこれ言ったんですかというと
我々は例えば幼稚園やら小学校に行ったところで
そこで最初に出会った先生がえらく機嫌が悪くて
親切 全くひとかけらも親切じゃなくて
もう何て言いますか
ちょっとしたことでも怒ったりする嫌な人だったら
その子供は一生学問というのは嫌になるでしょ
先生と言った途端 もうものすごく嫌になってくるんですね
私は実際にそういう人々を知っているんです
頭がいいんです 勉強もできる能力はよく見えるんです
でも勉強しない 途中で中退する
中学まで 中学も卒業しない
そういう中退した何人かの若者と付き合ってみたら
この人たちは結構頭がいいんです
すごい鋭い判断能力もあったんです
そこで私が聞いたんですね
何でお前らが学校に行かないんですかと
学校ぐらい卒業した方がなんとか便利でしょうと
言ったら言われたのは
もうなんとか
先生はこういうことをしたんだと
自分がやってもないことがね
好き勝手に自分だと思って調べようともしないで
もうさんざんもういろんなことを
言われるんだと批判されるんだと
そこで他の人でも何かやっちゃったら
まず疑われるのは私のことやと
でなんだこいつはと思って学校に
行くことをやめてしまったんだよと
そういうケース いくつか私が見ていたんだから
やっぱり先生がひどい先生だったら
これものすごい大変なことなんですね
それで一番大変なことは
最初の先生がいい加減な人だったら
いわゆる両親が あんまりもう無責任な人で
いい加減な人だったら
どうなるんでしょうかと
その子供の人生っていうのは必ずもう
不幸になってしまうんですね
それで世の中を見ると
親を殺す子供たちいるでしょうに
この子供に殺された場合は
よくそういうケース調べてみてください
ほとんどの場合は親がダメなんですね
全く当てにならない 賭け事にふけっているわ
酒愛好であるとかね ろくに仕事をしないとか
あるいは子供にも何でも何だかんだも怒鳴るとか
そういう性格ができてない
遊び回ってるとかそうするともうとんでもない
ろくでもない親　先生なんですね
それで子供に殺されちまっちゃう
我慢できないところで
それなんでそういう悲しい出来事が起こるかというと
この最初の先生が自分の役目を
果たしてないんだからなんです
それで 私が母親だ
私は父親だと思ったら
なんかうまくいかないところもあります
とこもあります ですから
子供が小さい子供がある両親
何を考えるべきかというと
もう母親父親どころじゃなくて
私はもう教師だと 教師だと思って
ちゃんと教師として子供に必要な
しつけをした方がいいんじゃないかなと
そうすると教師っていうのはよく知ってるんです
これいたちごっこみたいなもので
子供は勉強したくない
教師はやっぱりそれでも
教えてあげなくちゃいけないという遊び
ゲームなんですね 子供は逃げる
先生は追っていって なんとかして勉強させようとする
塾と違います　塾っていうのはこの世の中で
一番不自然なところなんですね
あれは単なる店なんですね
教育を売って金儲かっていうのは店です
それはもう大したことない
普通の美容室 薬局 そういうところと全く同じなんです
我々は薬局に行って
カツ丼ちょうだいって言わないでしょ
薬局に行ったら薬ちょうだいと言うだけであって
薬局に行ってカツ丼ちょうだい
何やってるんですか？あんた店やってるんではないか
という喧嘩しちゃうとあまり意味がないんです
だから塾っていうのはそんなもんで
もうそれほど大事なところじゃないんです
行く人はみんなもう教育を買うために行ってるんだから
そこで問題は起きません
でも本当の先生っていうのはもう大変な仕事なんです
この間もある塾の先生に聞いたんだけど
もう学校で教えることは大変苦しいんだと
でも塾はものすごい楽だと
なぜかというと 来る人々はもう決まってるんだと
勉強しなくちゃあかんと
だから教えて帰っちゃえばいいんですと
何ももう性格は云々とかね
行儀は云々とか そんなのは関係ない
服はなんでしょうか？とかね
髪型はどうしているんですか？とかね
そういうのは全然関係ない
どうでもいいんです こちらは教える
教えなかったら 勉強しなかったら向こうの損だけで
でも学校になるとそうじゃないんです
高校やら中学校だったら
子供たちはどうすれば勉強しないでさぼることできるかという
そればっかり考えている
先生も先生の責任があるんだから
どうすればこの子供たちが勉強するか
っていうことは考えなくちゃいけない
それは先生の大変な仕事なんです
ですから 両親も同じ立場になって
子供は行儀よくご飯は食べたくない
例えば小さな子供っていうのは
もう箸なんかは使えないんです
だから手で握って食べる
食べたいんですね そこで左手でも食べる
右手でも食べる で 手がもうものすごく汚れているのに
また何か触ったりもする
そうやってもう小さいんだから
もう何もそこからうまくできない
子供の立場から考えちゃうと
手で食べるのはこんなに簡単なのに
なんで親が箸使いなさいとか言うんですかと
めんどくさいではないかと
なんで食べながら走ったら悪いんですかと
じゃあ子供はもしかすると
おもちゃとかお人形とかあるんだったら
ご飯食べながらそれとも遊びたくなっちゃうでしょうね
ご飯食べてる途中でも
他の気が他のものに行ったらすぐそうやっちゃう
でそこで親が先生として
考えなくちゃいけないんですね
ただ怒ってダメですよなんとか言ったとしても
なんでダメですか？と
子供はわからないんですね
なんで遊んで悪いんですかと
だからそこら辺は先生としてどういう風に言ったら
その子はこれは理解してくれるかと
そこら辺だけ考えると
立派な親にはなります
ですから この両親は一番最初に覚えてほしいことは
自分たちがこのpubbācariyaであること
先生であること なんでそういうことを
またもう一つポイントがございます
どんな親でもよく考えることがありまして
子供っていうのは自分の何といいますか
財産だと 自分の所有物だと
思う傾向があるんです
あれも不自然です 子供と親の関係は動物見たらよくわかるんです
それとは別に何の変わりもないんです
その場合は動物から勉強した方がいいんです
動物はどのように子育てするんですかと
動物っていうのは立派な親で
きちんとすべて教えてあげるんですね
縄張りってどういうものかと
餌はどのように取るものかと
そういう全部教えてあげて
出て行けと 追い出すんです
どんな動物もそういうことをするんです
で 群れで生活する動物の場合も
もう追い出すんですね
自分の子供を追い出して群れの一員にしちゃうんです
一応群れの一員になってから
もう親子関係はないんです
全く一人前の扱いで甘えてあげることもしない
ですから 動物は子育てするときは
子供は自分の財産だと思って
一生子供を束縛されて奴隷にしようとはしないんです
ものすごく私に見えた一つの理由なんですけど
なぜ親と子がすごくトラブルを起こすかというと
親が子が自分の財産だと思っている
自分のもの 自分の所有物
私物だと思っている だから自分のものだから自分好きなようにすればいいと勘違いする
そこで人間っていうのはもう自由に生まれたものなんです
じゃあ皆様に違う質問をします
皆様方 自分の母親か父親かね
自分を奴隷にして 何でも命令したりして管理するんだったら
それがすごい気持ちいいんですかね
何一つも自由にさせない
全部親が決める
何か自分一人で何かやろうとしちゃったら
親がものすごく怒ってこれやめさせたりする
すべて親が言う通りにやらなくちゃいけないという羽目になったならば
それは気持ちいいんですかね
自分が結婚しても 親が来て
台所の中まで冷蔵庫の中まで
もう押入れの中まで全部調べて
なんでこういう風にあるんですか？なんでこういう風になるんですかとかね
こうしなさい こうしなさいと命令したり
会社に行こうとすると
またもう年取ってるおばあさんが
お母さんが来て あんたなんでその服着ているんですかと
ネクタイ変えなさいよとか
このシャツはダメですよと
そういう風に何でも言うと
会社にも電話かけてきて
あんたちゃんとしっかりやってるんでしょうかとかね
言っちゃうと あれ気持ちいいんですか？そこまでやっちゃうと
やっぱりもう親を殺したくなる気持ちはわかりますでしょうに
だから誰でも親を尊敬するんだけど
親の奴隷じゃないんです
だから自分の心に聞いてみてください
私のことを私の親が何だかんも管理するならば
私のことを私の親が何だかんでも管理するならば
私はそれ好きですか？と
そう考えちゃうと これこそ世の中で一番嫌なものです
会社に行ったらいろんなことを命令するのは
それほど気持ち悪くはないんです
それは会社にいる間のことだから
これは人生はもうずっと親に管理されちゃうと
それこそ世の中で一番嫌なことなんです
どこかの暴力団体に入ったところで
もう何だかんだも命令されるのは
それはそれほど嫌じゃないんです
自分の気持ちで入ったんだから
そちらのしきたり間違ったら殺される可能性もあるんだから
で しきたり聞いたら それなりになんとかうまくいくだろうということがあるんだけど
それよりも 例えばマフィアみたいな
この暴力団に入って もう完璧に命令されるように動かなくちゃいけない
それでも人間はそれほど嫌がらないんです
でもそれよりも嫌なのは両親が管理することなんです
ですから ものすごく覚えてほしいことが
自分の子供は決して自分の私物
所有物 財産ではないということ
自由な人間であると 自由にさせることが
自分の仕事だと それで子供小さい時からでも
やっぱり独立性に
独立になりたくて頑張っているんですね
だから親はすごい大きい
親の心 それを見て こいつは一人で何でもやりたがってますけど
まだまだダメだと まだ何もできないんだと
とまあ楽しく思いながら
もうちょっとお手伝いをしてあげる
例えばもう幼稚園に
あるいは小学校に行きたいんだけど
行かなくちゃあかんでしょうし
でもどこかで子どもはもうちょっと不安があったりする
その時はちょっとその不安をなくすようにしてあげる
まあ大丈夫だと みんな同じ年で
みんな同じことやっているんだからね
それぐらいでちょっと安心させてあげて
自由にする 幼稚園に子供と一緒に朝早く行って
幼稚園が終わるまでじーっと見張っているというのはね
それはやがて殺される可能性あります
そういうところか もう大学まで連れて行くんだから
日本では だから もし私が会社があったならば
もういくら才能があっても
そういう人は雇えません
ゴミですからね 役に立ちません
自分で判断能力は何もしないんでしょうし
それからこの2番目のポイントにも
もう言ってしまったんですけど
子供は所有物でない これは一人前の人間である
権利は平等である 社会人である
18歳あたりになるまでではなくて
生まれて自分でも何とか喋ったり
行動したりできた途端から
その瞬間から社会人なんですね
一応2歳になってくると家族の中の社会人でしょう
3歳になってくると 幼稚園という大きな組織の中の社会人でしょうに
4歳 5歳になってくると
小学校という大きな組織の社会人でしょうに
じゃあ親にできますかね
それは 社会人にしてあげること
そこは親の仕事なんですね
それも仏教から見る
人間の見方なんです 私の何者でもありません
これは社会人であると
この子は一番立派なのは
この地球の一人の人間であるというふうに育てたならば
すごい人間になるだろうと思います
あなたが地球で生まれてきた
地球の存在であると だから地球のおかげで生きてるんだから
地球人について 地球の生きている生命について
あなたには果たさなくちゃいけない
仕事がいっぱいあるんだよと
というふうなことを教えてあげると
それは一生役に立つんですね
そこをその 2つのポイントを覚えて
それからちょっと小さなポイントを
いくつかお話しします
なんか疲れました
この間 家で小さな子供を見たんだけど
子供は寝ていたんだけど
で 別な家に行って そこで
その子供を見たら お母さんがずっと子供のそばにいるんですね
見張ってるんです で ちょっと聞いた話は
子供が起きちゃったら機嫌が悪いんだから
できるだけ寝かせておくようにしているんですね
それでも子供は起きたんだけど
起きたら 子供は子供なりにいろいろ遊んだり
わがまま言ったりする
小さな子供だからね それで子供にはわからなかったんだけど
私は冗談で子供にこういうことを言ったんですね
もうあんたね いろいろお母さんに要求しても
お母さんはもう慣れてないんだと
子供育てることにはもう初めてやっていることだと
だから何だかんだと要求されてもできませんよと
それは 子供にわかることじゃないんだけど
そこで大人にちょっとした言葉を言っただけなんですね
で 子供っていうのは自分の母親
父親しか知りませんし
だから自分に対して完璧に接しなさいということ
要求が子供持ってるんです
おむつ替える時でも ご飯食べさせてあげる時でも
寝かしてあげる時でも
起こしてあげる時でも
何だかんでもきちんと自分の希望通りに
完璧にやりなさいよと
子供はちゃんと要求する
でも不思議なこと 母親っていうのはもう経験ないんですよ
初めて生まれた子供だから
何も一つもわからないんですね
父親にしても もう 100人ぐらい子供育てた経験あると
経験者じゃないんでしょうに
例えば学校だったら 先生っていうのは特別訓練受けてるでしょ
教えること 世の中で親だけ何も訓練を受けてないんです
それなのにものすごい大事な仕事を
任されているんですね
仕事に 世の中で一番難しい仕事に
一人の生命を人間に仕立てること
だから世の中のおかしいということは
世の中で一番難しい仕事は
全く経験ない人に 委託して任せていることなんです
それはよく覚えておいてください
自分たちには 子育てにはもう全然経験も訓練もないんだと
だから暗闇で手探りながら
やらなくちゃいけないことなんですね
だから これ大変なことなんです
それでどういうことかというと
父親と母親がずーっと自分に経験ないこと
上手にできないことをよく覚えて
徹底的に勉強しなくちゃいけないんですね
どこで勉強するかというと
自分の子供から勉強しなくちゃいけないんです
私は昔よく使った言葉がありまして
子供っていうのは大学ですと
いろんな科目がありまして
それぞれまたそれなりにえらい専門的な学部ですね
大学っていうのは 学校と違って
学校でもいろんなことを教えるんだけど
専門的じゃないんですね
だから子供っていうのも大学みたいなもんで
いろんなことを両親に教えているんですね
だから私はこういうふうに解釈するんですね
子供は泣いたりすること
例えばすごい小さい子供だったらよく泣く
この泣くということは
親に一つの宿題 研究テーマを出しているんです
親はもうそういう経験
前なかったんだからわからない
なんで子供は泣いてるんでしょうかと
そこで これは自分に出された研究テーマだ
それまた現場で今すぐ発見しなくちゃいかないんだと
ですから もうたまに間違ってもいいんだから
間違いながらも なんで子供は泣いてるんでしょうかと
それは発見する 私が見たところで発見することじゃなくて
なんとかごまかす 子供が泣いちゃうと
何とかしてごまかして
もう泣かないようにする
それもその場合によって悪くはないんだけど
いつでもごまかせばいいっていうことじゃないんです
ですから子供は泣くということさえも
自分に宿題出してるんです
それを発見する そうすると自分の勉強になる
これは例えば 3ヶ月間ぐらい
そうやって子供を観察しちゃうと
大体母親っていうのは泣いただけでわかるんですね
あれもうお腹が空いてるんだ
あれは遊びたがってるんだとかね
今はなんか暑すぎですよと
今はちょっと寒くて泣いてるんだよと
すぐわかるようになるんです
ただ泣き声だけで で そういう風に自分で
子供を大学にしてしまって研究する
そこをやっちゃうと 決して育児ヒステリーにはなりません
この育児ヒステリーという病気がありますね
あれは何ですか？と 子供は泣くわ泣くわ
何やっても泣き止まない
それで嫌になってくるんですね
自分にも寝る暇もないし
そういうものすごく泣く子がちょっと
大きくなってきて泣きはやめますけど
それからまたわがままで
あれこれ これが嫌
あれが嫌というものすごいわがままになっちゃうんです
その時もう言葉を喋れるんだから
母親をもうカンカン怒ってヒステリーになるんですね
だから気持ちとしては子供を育てたいんだけど
どうもうまくいかない
それでぶったり殴ったり
あのあれ 何て言いますか
虐待したりする　そこで虐待する母親たちの
話をテレビで見ていたんだけど
自分の子供だからものすごく可愛いんだと
虐待は全然したくないんだと
それでも泣いたりわがまま言ったりすると
ついやってしまっちゃいますよと言って
自分のことも怖くなってくるんですね
その問題解決する方法っていうのは
子供っていうのはもうえらい大学で
ものすごい難しい研究課題を出しちゃうんですね
これをやりなさいと だから子供はもう生まれた時からものすごく泣く場合も
母親がなんとか
泣くことさえやんでくれればいいやという気持ちで抑えよう
抑えよう 抑えようとする
だからヒステリーが起こしちゃうんですね
ですから いろんな方法を試してみて
試してみたところで 子供はなんで泣くの？っていうことが見つかるんです
いろんな理由はあるんです
一番皆様にはそれほど問題ないと思いますけど
時々このホルモンのバランスがあまり良くなくて
親の食べ物やら生きる環境とか
それですごく胎児に影響を与えるんだから
ものすごい神経質に生まれる場合もあります
あまりにも神経質で赤ちゃんが生まれる前から
もうものすごいストレスの塊で生まれる時あります
ですから子供にとってはすごく
これ我慢できないんですね
体がすごい小さい 心は大人と同じなんです
心のエネルギーが だから巨大な心のエネルギーでストレス溜まって
この小さな体の中で それはなんとか処理しなくちゃいけないでしょうし
そうするとものすごく泣いたりする
だから そこは一番大変な問題なんですけど
なんで生まれた瞬間からもう
それほどストレス溜まってるかと
それはやっぱり親がね
妊娠中の生き方やら食べた食べ物やら環境やら
そういういろんなものの影響もあります
だからこれかなりの研究課題なんです
子供が泣くということさえも
なんで泣くかということさえも
一人私が昔知っていた子供がいて
母親が日本人で父親が外国人なんですね
そこでこの子供は育てる環境では
この父親の方の人間がたくさん手を貸す
いろいろと子育てに でも子供は日本で育てるんだから
子供の心の中の文化はもう完璧に日本文化なんですね
小さい時だからしょうがないでしょうし
自分が完璧に日本の文化の中の人間なのに
自分にご飯を作ってくるおばあちゃんが
違う文化で日本語も喋れない
そこで子供と遊ぶ時でも
ちょっと文化が違う 子供は何かわがままを要求したとしても
対応のやり方が違う 日本的じゃない
それでものすごくその子にはストレスなんですね
そこでこの外国のグループが全然それを理解しない
理解もできない 私はあの子もかなりの被害者だと
そこでこの日本の母親がもうほとんどいい加減で
それほど子育てには手を出さない
できるだけ手を引こうとする
でも子供が日本文化に文化的な
育ち方がもう慣れたもので
それ要求しているんですね
そこである日こういうことを見たんだ
子供は泣くわ泣くわ もういくら抱っこしたとしても
ものすごくもう嫌で嫌で
おじいさんにもおばあちゃんにももう誰にもできない
そこで そこら辺にいた全くも関係ない
その人々 誰かともわからない
ある日本のおばさんが
全く知らない人なんですけど
その子供を抱っこしたんです
すぐ泣き止んじゃったんです
だから考えてください
小さな子供っていうのは
全く知らない人に抱っこしたら
全然機嫌が悪いでしょうに
知らない人に抱っこしたとしても
それは嫌でしょうにすぐ自分の親戚のところに
飛んで行っちゃうでしょうに
やっぱりあの子は知らない日本の
おばさんに抱っこしちゃったら
もう何のことなくもう泣き止めて
そういう風にもういろいろ
子供にとっては問題があるんです
そこで私が理解したのは
やっぱりこれは文化の違いだと
子供は日本文化にもう小さいだから
この2つの文化にまだ慣れるのは早い
いきなり身に入った文化は受け取っちゃって
それは基準にしている
だから知らないおばさんでも抱っこしちゃったら
日本語で喋ってくれるし
対応する言葉もそれなりに子供にふさわしい言葉でしょうし
それで落ち着いてしまったんですね
ですから この 子供を泣いたっていうことは
我々にとってはもう大学研究課題
そこを研究しなくちゃいけない
大勢の場合はすぐ発見できます
どうしても泣き止まない場合は
何か病院にでも連れて行って
体の状態はどうでしょうかとかね
そういうことを理解した方がいいんですね
もう一つ言いますけど
小さな子供たちもいる
お母さんたちが見えますから
自分の子供がずっと寝てるでしょ？大体
寝ていたら目が覚めた瞬間で子供を見てください
この目が覚めた瞬間で
子供の態度がその子の基本的な性格なんです
そこで その子はどのように育てればいいか
ということを発見できます
だから この子供の性格がわからないんだ
わからないんだというのは
ちょっと寂しいことなんです
だから 子供は遊んでいる時やら
もうニコニコと笑って遊んでいる時なんかは性格見えません
すごく怒ってキャーキャーと泣いている時でも
あんまり性格は見えません
そこでじーっと寝ていて目が覚めるでしょうに
目が覚めた瞬間で自分一人なんですね
この一人で目が覚めたら子供はどんな対応をするかと
そこで子供の基本的な性格を見えますから
それからそこに合わせて
育てればいいんです
わかりやすい例で言えば
時々目が覚めた途端泣くんだけど
誰かがそばにそこら辺いるんだったら
泣かない子がいるんですね
それは寂しがり屋ですね
一人でいたくない と すぐわかるんです
寂しがり屋だと そこでまた目が覚めたらすぐ泣く
泣いたところで母親が来て抱っこして
慰めてあげない限りは泣き止めない
いわゆる機嫌が悪いんですね
目が覚めたら それは結構
わがままなんですね
激しい 赤ちゃんだから見えないだけなんですが
大人になったら大変激しい性格になります
そこを覚えておいてください
ああ この子はかなりわがままだと
それから 目が覚めた途端
何のことなくすぐ笑う
一人でも笑って遊ぶという子もいるんですね
それはあたりまえで
かなり明るい それほど手がかからない子ですね
この子はすごく明るくて
それほど手がかからないと
そこでもちょっとした
それでもちょっとした引っ掛けがあるんです
時々子供がいるんですね
小さい時からもうやっぱり大人の機嫌を取ろうとする
よく笑ってあげる で もう誰手を出しても
おばあちゃん手を出しても
おじいさん手を出しても
お父さん手を出しても
兄弟誰が手を出しても すぐもう抱っこしてもらうと
そうやって みんなの機嫌を取る子もいます
これは赤ちゃんの時でもあります
その性格 それも大体目が覚めた瞬間でよくわかります
それも一つの性格なんですね
もしかすると そういう子が成功する可能性もあるし
人の機嫌を取るんだからね
あれは悪く言っちゃえば
ちょっとずるいずる賢い人間に
なってしまう場合もあります
それは親の仕事 いい方向へ持っていくことは
たとえものすごい我が強くて
荒っぽい赤ちゃんであろうとも
それは良くないことだということは
それからコツコツと教えてあげればいいことだからね
基本的な性格は何であろうとも
良い方向へ育てるのが親の仕事なんですね
そういう風に子供っていうのは
大学だと思って接しちゃうと
結構やりがいがあると思います
大変ですよ かなり自分の頭が鋭く回らないと
例えば言葉を喋るようになったら何でも聞くでしょ
あれは何？これは何？これは何ですか
これは何ですかとかね
何でも聞くんだけども
親が困るんですね こんなこと教えたってわかるわけないでしょうと
で そこら辺でも親の宿題ですよ
研究課題なんですね  2つあります
一つは 子供は別にあれを聞いてるんじゃないんです
ただ 初めて習った日本語の訓練してるだけ
単語を覚えなくちゃいけないし
ですから 何であろうとも
あれはなんで？と聞く
ご飯もう米を洗っていると
なんで洗っているんですかと
それは汚いんだから綺麗にするためだと
じゃあなんで綺麗にするんですか？と
ついまたなんでが入ってくる
それぐらいは答えられますけどね
なんでスイッチ入れるんですか？とかね
なんで待ってるんですか？と
もう何でもなんでなんでとか
もうこれやりきれないぐらい聞くんですね
その場合もやっぱり一つは
子供は言葉を覚えてる段階があります
それ終わったらすぐ情報を獲得する段階に入るんですね
そこを覚えておいて 情報を獲得する段階になってくると
ちゃんと論理的に情報を与えなくちゃいけないんです
ごまかしてはいけません
これ難しいんですよ だから大学だからしょうがないでしょうに
難しいんだからやめたっていうことは
そんないきませんから
だから一番悪いことに
子供が一番知りたがるのはね
自分がどうやって生まれてきたんですか？とかね
一番説明しにくいところなんですけど
子供はそれを先に知りたがるんですね
どうすればいいかと
どう説明すればいいかとわからなくなりますけどね
それももう自然な流れで
なぜならば 子供は自分の存在にもう気づいているんですね
だから親にすごくかわいがってもらって
すごく元気で生きている
そういう自分どのように出てきたんでしょうかと
という自分に対する興味なんです
そこでこうのとりが持ってきたとかね
言ってもやっぱりね そう言わない方がいいんです
何にも根拠もない嘘
自分小さい時
自分も同じ質問したんですけど
覚えているんだからね
で 言われたのはそこら辺から拾ってきたんだと
で そこら辺から拾ってきて
一生懸命育てるんだと
ということでまたもうあまり泣いたりして
わがまま言うなよという感じなんですね
そういう聞いたらすごく悲しくなっちゃったんですね
結局は もうすごい小さいんだから
ただなんか嫌な気持ちが出たんだけど
どうしようもないんですね
もう言葉を喋れませんから
現代はね それほど問題も昔ですからね
いろいろ道徳世界っていうのは厳しい時代で
我々育てられちゃったんだからね
今はそれほど問題はないんですけどね
でも 2番目の子には教えやすいんだけどね
1番目は難しいんですよ
ただ また逆に 1番目一番経験ないんだから
上の子を育てる場合はね
2番目の子が出てくると
やっぱりもう上の子にはね
お腹の中にもう一人子供がいるんだよ
っていうことは教えてあげることはできますけど
だからその質問は必ず来る
何のことなく本当のことを言っちゃえばいいんです
問題ないんです お腹の中でこういう風に
こういう風に出てきたんだよと
あまりわかりません 子供はそういうことを言っても
でも本当のことを言うと
なるほど大変なことをやっている
ことぐらいは覚えておくんですね
寂しくはならないんです
ある子供が母親にキウイという果物ありますね
キウイフルーツという緑色のあまり美味しくない果物
美味しくないんだけど
体にいいんですけどね
あれはあのつる２つないと実りませんね
雄しべというかね 花がね
あの雌しべと言うんですか
それ別々なつるで花が咲くんですね
だから 実って欲しければ
2つちゃんと育てないとできない
ある子供に私は何のことなくもう何でも聞くんだから
これはこういう雄しべのつるで
これは雌しべが出るつるで
その2つ一緒になるんだから
いっぱい実がなってるんだよ
と言っただけで それで両親に聞くんですね
なんでそういう風になって
私はもうあまりもう説明したくない状態でしたからね
なんで雄しべと雌しべがなければ実らないかと
果物が出てこないかと聞いたら
もう親には説明できなくて
そこで親がじゃあ私に聞いてくださいと
それで私は何のことなく
普通の学校で教えるような感じで
あの こういう風に受粉のことやらね
で そうやって別々なものを繋げたら
もう実るんだよと言ったんですね
それで次の質問というのは
やっぱりもうなぜそういうふうに
ならなくちゃいけないんですか？と言ったら
世の中はどこでも見なさいよ
鳥でもみんなそうやってもう二人
二人一緒になって子供を作るんだと
で ＤＮＡのことまで言って
そういうふうなことで
このお互いに混ぜることで病気にならないで
元気で健康で長生きできるんだと
もしそうやって混ぜることなかったならば
もうすぐ亡くなってしまっちゃいますよと
子供はよく知っている恐竜とかいるんだからね
そういう恐竜やいろんな動物が亡くなったんだと
それで子供が分かったかないか分かりませんけど
もうすごいいろんなことを言うと
ああ そうですかと とにかく一応分かりましたからね
だからあんまりこの子供にはそんなこと
分からないんだということじゃなくて
それは理解できるようにいろんな方法を使って
教えるのはやっぱり先生の仕事なんですね
先生というのは親のことなんですけど
それから例えば教え方なんですけど
子供は例えばおにぎり食べていますね
よく子供たちが好きだから
おにぎり なんで好きでしょうかね
あれ 食べやすいからかもしれませんね
よくもうつかまれるし
海苔はどんな子供でもね
大変好物ですからね 海苔もあるし
もう取りやすいし 食べやすいかもしれません
わかりません 私は小さい時
おにぎり食べなかったんだからわかりません
それで子供というのは
おにぎり食べながら床を触ったりする
私は日本の子供たちと親の感じを
よくじっと見ているんですね
えらい清潔好きなんですけど
ものすごい不潔なんです
頭だけで清潔好きで 実際には不潔なんです
そこで私だったらもう床やらいろんな
みんなもう草履履いて歩いたりするところでね
子供はどうせぺちゃぺちゃとそれ触ったりするんですね
それでおにぎりのご飯ちょっとでも落ちたら
すぐそれを拾って食べるんですね
大体の場合 親が何も言わないんですね
あんなみっともないこと大人もやってるんだから
それで私はそういうことはなんで気をつけるかというと
床っていうのはもう細菌だらけでしょうね
ホコリやら細菌やら汚いもの
それで子供の小さなもうもうなんてますだ平らだから
手は我々よりもきちんと
もうなんかもう猫の手みたいな感じでね
ふっくらしているでしょう
だからべったりとホコリやら細菌やら手に付くんですね
だからその場合は 子供にちょっとしたドラマで教えてあげればね
あー手の中でまあ細菌いっぱいだ
嫌だとかね お母さんのところに来るなよ
手が細菌だらけで汚いよとかね
あ 怖いと まあちょっと冗談でね
あ私の食べ物だけは触らないでくださいとかね
これこれ汚い汚い あなたの手がもう汚く汚くなっちゃったんだからと
そんなことちょっと一回だけやっちゃうと
子供はすぐ勉強するんですね
このただ 見た目の清潔ではなくて
論理的な清潔はもっと必要だと
子供の服なんか汚れたって
これは大したことはないんです
食べる時はもう顔中ご飯あっちこっちやっても
これは別にどうったことはない
である 小さな赤ちゃんがね
なんか私は抱っこしてあげたら
もうすぐ私の手をつかまって
それもうしゃぶっちゃうんですね
自分の手はしゃぶらない
で これ私は冗談に言いながらね
まあ言いながら指を上げちゃいましたけど
すごくその赤ちゃんのところにいた時は
ものすごく気をつけたんです
自分の手が汚れないようにと
だから何か触ったらすぐ行って
もうごしごしと石鹸で手を洗っておく
なぜかというと 赤ちゃんを抱っこしちゃったら
すぐもう指に指を狙っちゃいますからね
ですから まあそういうふうな
例えばちゃんと手を洗いなさいよと命令するより
それは命令も必要ですけど
やっぱりその中にそれなりの理屈があるんだよと
そこはちょっとした面白いことで
もう冗談で言っちゃえばよく理解する
大体どんな子供でもおかしいこと好きなんですね
で 子供が好きな漫画やらね
なんで子供はそれほどモンスターが好きですかね
どんな子供でも もうポケットの中でね
ポケモンのカードいっぱいあるでしょ
あんなもん大人から見れば何なのかと
これはと むちゃくちゃであれ
おかしいんだから もう変だから子供は好きなんです
だからもう子供っていうのは本当はしつけしやすいんです
だから なんか言う場合は
すごくドラマティックでオーバーに言う
自分はそれで漫才師になってちゃんと演じてみせる
それ親にとってもすごくリラックスできる気持ちいいものだと思いますね
だって自分の漫才 誰も聞いてくれませんからね
だから そういうのを子供に日常生活のことは
もう何か手を洗わないでご飯食べたこととかね
それはちょっとドラマにして
手を洗わなくてご飯食べてお腹が壊しちゃって
もうもうゲロを出したり
いろいろ苦労したりすることを
自分でドラマでやっちゃえば
勝手に 子供はやっぱり
聞いていないふりをするんだけど
ちゃんと聞いてるんです
あるちっちゃな女の子に
親がもうちゃんと自分のものはちゃんと
自分で片付きなさいと教えてあって
で 女の子だから そういうのはちゃんと言われたらやりますからね
それでその子の家で私はガムを食べたんですね
で 私は机でもう紙を
開いて ガムを口に取ったら
やっと言葉を喋れるぐらいですけどね
出てきて もうちゃんと自分でそのゴミをね
自分食べたものは自分でちゃんと
片付けてくださいと私に言うんです
あんまり やっと言えたぐらいの
日本語の能力なんですけど
幼稚園には行ってなかったんですね
だから 言うことはちゃんと理解はしている
だから私はもう子供に負けたらね
子供に言われたら これは大人として立場がないんだから
でも これはもう君の家でしょ
だからゴミ箱は知りませんね
私がどこにあるかと 知ってますかと
うん 知ってますと じゃあこれちょうだいと言って
子供にもまた もう逆襲しちゃったんだけど
言われたんだから やっぱりそれでも私は
何かちょっともう一つ教えてあげただけで
自分の家だから やっぱりお客さんには
ちゃんと案内することも必要だよと
もし私が勝手に台所に行ってゴミ箱に入れてたら
もう子供はその勉強はしない
大人にも言ってやったぞという気持ちになるでしょうね
だから私は人の子供でも
もうちょっと 30 分遊んであげても
これは大変な自分の勉強になるんだとは思ってるんです
ですから 親 たちがみんな
子供からいっぱい学べるんだよと
覚えておけば ちょっとやり方
例でそういうふうに言いましたけどね
例えば文字を教える時でも
もういろんなストーリーで
遊びで 恐竜やらね
そういうモンスターやらね
そういう言葉借りて 言うとすぐ早く覚えちゃうんですね
子供はひらがなの「は」書こうと思って
「ま」書いたとする
それで「は」の字にはもうなんとか
なんて言いますか
付き人必要だよと お連れがいるんだと
「ま」は 一人で大丈夫やと
でも「は」はダメですよと
で たくさんなければね
そういうふうに これ私は今作った考え出したストーリーで
やっぱりそれなりに自分の国の文字だったら
いろいろストーリー作ってあげないと
例えば自分の国の文字の場合は
「な」と「た」っていうのはほぼ似ているんです
子供には区別できないんで
ちょっと例で書いてみせます
上の字は「な」で 下の字は「た」なんです
どちらが違いますかね
これは外国の方々には外国っておかしいんだけど
自分の国の言葉を知らない方々にとっては
えらい難しいと思いますよ
わかりますか？差はどこら辺違うかと
上はですね どっちかというと
顔を上げてるんですね
うん そうですね  下はですね
おじぎしてる  そうそうそう
その差なんですね それ
印刷文字になっちゃうと
もっとひどいんです もう手で書いたんだから
いくらかちょっと手の癖が入りますからね
こんなちょっとの差なんです
顔を上げてるか下げてるかってぐらいの
子供にとってはこれはえらい苦しいんですよ
だから子供に教える時は
もう「な」はね お腹が空いて上見てるんだと
「た」はもうお腹がいっぱい
だからもういらんと下向いてるんだと
ご飯にはスリランカ語でバッタという
言葉で「た」を使っちゃうんです
だからご飯もそうでしょ
だからもうお腹がいっぱいで
お腹がいっぱいで 顔ももういらんと下見ているんだと
「な」はもうお腹が空いてるんだからもうちょうだいと
顔を上げているんだというふうに言えば
子供にとってそれはちょっとしたストーリーなんですね
だから そのストーリーですぐ
覚えてしまう そうやって子供の世界っていうのは
いつでも楽しみがいっぱい世界なんですね
だから道徳を教える時でも
いつでも子供にその面白さっていうのは
楽しみっていうのは利用して
指導しなくちゃいけないんです
それ 文字を教えるのは別に
親の仕事ではないかもしれませんけど
そんなことは学校でもできますけど
親の仕事は人間育てることなんですね
道徳を教えることなんです
それ どうやればいいんでしょうかね
例えば怒るなよと
怒るなよっていうことを
どうやって教えればいいんですかね
それ その自分の家庭の環境から
教えてあげてください
今はちょっとあまり良い例じゃないんだけど
例えば子供が何とかのことで怒ったらね
で 君がね お母さんがカンカン怒るのは好きですか？と
あるいはいつでもお母さんがニコニコと笑っているのは好きですか？と
君のことを怒るのは好きですか？あるいは君のことを可愛がってあげるのは好きですか？と
そしたら答えは決まっててね
怒るのは嫌だと ですから
誰でも怒るのは嫌だよと
君もカンカン怒っちゃうとお母さんがものすごい嫌ですよと
それもちょっとオーバーには
もうすごい嫌ですねとかね
言ったらまあ怒ってはいけないということは
そこでなんとかわかるでしょうと思います
なんでもそうやって例を出して言うんです
大人よりも子供の頭っていうのはものすごい論理的なんです
我々から見れば なんだこの子は
というふうに気持ちはあるんだけど
すごい論理あるんです
例えば 子供がものすごい変な絵なんか描くでしょ
大人から見れば
どうせ子供の絵だからということで
でも聞いてみてください
聞いてみたら そちらに理屈はあるんです
例えば人間の絵を描いて
頭の上で花があるというの描くかもしれません
それどう見ても変でしょうね
頭の上から花が咲くはずがないでしょうに
子供だからそんな変なこと
描くんだよということではなくて
子供に聞いてみてください
なんでこちらこの花があるんでしょうかと言ったら
自分が何を考えて描いたかということを教えてくれる
聞いてみれば
すごい論理的なんです
もしかすると その子が
いえ この人がさっきこの花畑で寝ていたんだよと
で だからそちら頭に花が咲いているんだということを言うかもしれません
その場合は その子供が花畑で寝ていた人がすごい気持ちよく起きたことを描いているんです
そんなに表現力ないんだから
もうそこはわからないだけのことで
だからその場合は感心できるんですね
ある子がちょっとした街を描いて
それなりに人も描いて
それからもうなんかもうブラウン色ですか
色で全部線でもう消しちゃったんですね
絵を完璧に もう見えない
描いたものは で 消してから偉そうに私に持ってくるんです
絵を描いたんだから はい
どうぞと 大人の目で見れば
自分描いた絵を全部むちゃくちゃ
ブラウン色で茶色のクレヨンで消しちゃって
これちょっとどうかなと思うでしょうね
私は別にもう感動も何もなし
あの なんで君がこの絵を全部
消しちゃったんですか？と言ったら
答えはこれは雨の音
だから結局子供が雨の中の街を描いたんですね
だから子供の世界で雨が降る時
一番気になるのは音なんですね
すごい音ですからね だから音を描いたんですよ
だから音を描いただけなんです
それで あ なるほど よくできてますと
全部消して音が強いということなんです
それを言ったのは 子供っていうのは
こんなもうふざけて遊んでいるんだけど
いい加減じゃないんです
ちゃんと論理的に物事を考えているんです
だから我々も子供にしつけするときは
すごく丁寧に 何でも
変な理屈ではないんです
ただ論理的だけなんです
すごく緩やかな優しい論理で
で 自分の母親が自分が小さい時
鳥を捕まえようとしたところで
ちょっとした箱の蓋をね
もう外を入れて そこで棒を一つ挿しておいて
ロープをつなげて もう家で隠れて待ってるんですね
餌を食べるために鳥来るまで
そこで棒を引っ張っちゃえば
もう箱の中に鳥が捕まれるんですね
それ狙ってもう二人で待っていると
母に見つかったんですね
母に見つかったら 母言うのは
君を誰かがそうやってね
罠をかけて捕まえて持っていったとする
どこかに知らないところに持っていって
何か檻に入れて出られないように鍵かけておくと
どうですかね その時はと
だから母親言うことだから
インパクト強く心に響くんですね
そうするといきなり頭の中でイメージが
出来上がっちゃったんですね
誰か自分を知らない人が自分を捕まえて
何か檻に入れて鍵をかけて入れておくと
私は考え そこでお母さんに会えなくなっちゃう
遊ぶこともできなくなっちゃう
お母さんのご飯も食べられなくなっちゃうと
そこを頭にイメージが出てきたんですね
あ これ悲しいんだと やっぱりやってはアカンと
それでもう動物いじめることをやめてしまったんです
そういう風に小さい時
いろんな道徳を教えてくれたんだけど
正直にすることと 嘘を言ってはいけないことと
もう約束したことはちゃんとやること
何だかんでも全部自分の人生の中から
イメージを湧くようにして
イメージが湧くようにして教えたんです
それで一生どんな人間で生きるべきかということは
母親がもうちゃんと叩き込んじゃうんですね
独立するべきであることも
ちょっとしたことであっても
母が結構病気になるということするんですね
もうこれでもう大変だと
それで子供たちってわがまま言うんだからね
病気になったりしたとしても
ご飯どう食べるんでしょうかとかね
そういうわがままを言われるまでなんとなくいるんですね
言ったらすぐ言うのは
私たちはもう年だからすぐ死んじゃいますよと
あんた方はずっと母に甘えるつもりですか？と
自分のことを自分でできなかったら
もう生きていられませんよと
人はいつ死ぬかわかりませんと
兄弟喧嘩するときでも
あんた方はずっと一緒に
もう仲良くすることになってるんだと
両親っていうのは 母親も父親も先に死んじゃいますよと
そういう風なことを言っちゃうと
やっぱり兄弟喧嘩してはいけないとかね
いくら嫌でも我慢してでもいなくちゃあかんと
いつでも母が来て守ってくれるわけじゃないんだと
そこで愛情についても
自分の母が教えたのは
それは自分で努力して買うものであって
ただで貰うものじゃないんだと
だから子供は一人しかないと
もうやりたい放題のことをやってあげるでしょうね
それはすごい 子供にとってはものすごい悪いことなんですね
だから私 これは兄弟大きいんで
家族大きいんだったらね 簡単ですけどね
だから良いことをすれば
もうそれなりに言うことをちゃんと聞いて
きちんと正しく生きているならば
母親がよく褒めて ちょっとかわいがってくれる
ほんのちょっとだけ そういうこと何もなくても
ただ一日中遊んだだけだったら
だいたいほとんど無視されちゃうんですね
あなたもいるんですかという態度なんですね
自分の母親が そこで一日何かもう何かいいことをしたら
もう母親のお手伝いやら
家の何かとか なんとかね
掃除でもしてあげたら
そこでちょっと褒めてくれる
それも少々 大胆ではないんですね
それで自分が何を学んだかというと
人に助けて欲しければ
人に面倒見て欲しければ
自分がそれ努力して買わなくちゃいけないんだと
その技はもうずっと 自分にも役に立ちましたからね
だってもう13になったところで
もうお寺に入ったし 全く知らない世界で
そこで子供としてはすごく寂しくなる可能性ありましたし
いじめられる可能性もありましたし
どこでもそういうことには遭ったことはないんです
自分で計算して この人には怒られてもどうでもいいや
ということの人の場合はあまり気にしない
でも この人が親切にしてくれなかったら
自分が大変だと ということはちゃんと理解して
その人々に可愛がってもらうように
いろいろなことをするんです
だから 一旦大学に入った時からもう自分で
この先生はすごく頭が鋭そうやと
いろんなことを知ってるやと
だったら その先生に何とかして接近する
接近して 自分をアピールして
なんとか 印象を埋めておくんですね
印象を埋めて とにかく愛情を買ってもらうんですね
それでもうそれで大丈夫です
なんでも心配してくれるし
何か間違ってもすごく優しくね
教えてくれるし だから
この専門的なこと以外
人間としていろんなことを
そういう先生方はね もう何から何まで教えてくれる
だから大人の世界で生きていた時でも
すごく気持ちが分かったんですね
ですから母親を教えることっていうのは
一生役に立つ大変大事なこと
そこは覚えてほしいんですね
まとめて結論で言うならば
両親の仕事っていうのは人間育てること
どこにいても立派な人間になること
会社の社長になろうが
もうただのサラリーマンでなろうが
やっぱり自分が立派な人間で生きていられる
人に嘘をつかない 人を騙すということはしない
ちょっとしたことでカンカンと怒らない
忍耐はある 何かやりたければ
何か獲得したければ いちいち文句言わないで
どんな苦しみも自分で決めたものだから
それは乗り越える
そういう風な人格ですね
だから短い言葉で覚えてください
両親の仕事は子供の人格を形成することですね
それは学校の仕事でもありますけどね
宿題のお手伝いすることは別にどうでもいいんで
そんなことは できるんだったらやってもよろしいし
忙しいんだったら放っておいてください
それは勝手にしなさい
あんたの宿題でしょうと
やってもやらなくても
お母さんが学校に行かないんだから
大丈夫だと威張っちゃえばいいんです
お母さんは大丈夫や 宿題やってもやらなくても怒られませんと
ただ 怒られる人がいるんだったら
自分で宿題すればいいでしょうというふうな態度でも
別にどうったことはないんです
でも人格は形成することはやっぱり親の仕事なんですね
それからいろいろ経典から
話を続けていきたいんですが
どうですかね 疲れたでしょうかね
じゃあ次のポイントに入る前に
あの前の今まで喋ったことの結論として
覚えてほしいことを言いますけど
親にはこの愛情っていうのは危険です
愛情というのは苦しみしか作ってくれないんです
子供に対する愛情ではなくて
慈しみなんです 必要なのは
仏教はやっぱり愛とかね
そういう執着とかね そういうのはすごく危険だと
毒だと 苦しみしか何一つも作ってくれないんだと
頭がおかしくなるんだと
バカになるんだと 愛情で
欲情で頭いっぱいになったら
もう完璧にアホになるんです
何もわからなくなっちゃうんです
だからバカになることだけは
ものすごい良くないんですね
バカな人は 狂った人は何するかわからないでしょ
世の中の両親たちっていうのは
子供に対してものすごい強烈な愛情を持ってるんですね
だから何一つもわからない
頭狂ってるんです
それですごい苦しみが生まれてくる
我慢できなくなる 子供のためなら人殺しでもする
そこは苦しみの道なんですね
その代わりにお釈迦様がおっしゃったのは
慈しみを育てなさいと
それは独立した人間であって
自分に責任ある 立派な人として育ててあげることは
そこで地球人の地球の一人として育てるんだと
慈しみっていうのは全然
苦しみは作ってくれないんです
そこは大事なポイントで
この愛情を捨てて 子供に対して
やっぱりすごくこの慈しみを育てる
慈しみっていうのは これ私のものではありませんということなんです
でも すごい大事な命 私の命ではありません
私のものではありません
ですから 大事な命ですから
大事に幸せで幸福でいてほしいと
間違いを起こしてほしくないと
例えば 自分の子供が学校で他の子供をいじめたとする
それ見つかったら
親がもうむちゃくちゃでしょうに
うちの子はそんなことはしませんと
何と言うんでしょうかとか
そういう態度をするんですね
そういう態度をとっちゃうと
学校もいじめの問題は処理できなくなっちゃうんです
どうせいじめるんだったら子供にも問題あるんだけど
それも親の愛情がないっていうことですけど
愛情というか優しさがないからなんですが
それでいきなり子供がトラブルを起こしたところで
偉そうに愛情あるんだということは子供に見せようとする
そして子供さえも自分がやったことは
良くないとわかっているのに
親が弁解するんですね
そういう変なことをするんだから
もう学校にしても
教える先生たちと もう両親の間ではそれほど仲のいい関係じゃないんですね
だから慈しみさえあれば
自分の子供が悪いことをしたら
それは全くもう何のことなく
あ なるほど うちの子が悪いんだと
それは認めてあげないと
ですから その時にやっぱり世の中で悪いことは悪い
良いことは良い これはたとえあなた
私の娘であろうが 息子であろうが
悪いことをしたら 両親にはどうすることもできないんだと
あんた犯罪を起こしたら
あんた犯罪者であると
私は守ってくれると思ったら
それは勘違いだと 私には何もできませんと
あんたは世の中の人間ですからね
世の中の考え方 倫理や道徳をね
それは理解して行動しなくちゃいけないんだと
そういうふうに言えるんですね
慈しみさえあれば ですから
正しく子供を育てる秘訣は
もう愛情を捨てて慈しみを
育てるということなんですね
そこでちょっと五分ぐらいお休みをいただいて
経典の話に入ります
ものすごいたくさんありますけどね
言いたいことは
仏教の世界で
これからちゃんと仏教の話だけに絞りますが
仏教の世界でもやっぱりよく子供を
預かって育ててきたということは
我々歴史的にもあることで
で お釈迦様の時代でもね
そういう親のない子供たちとかね
見つかったらお寺というかね
連れていくんですね
連れて行って 育てるんだけど
決して在家の人を通して
育てることはしなかったんですね
お寺に連れてきて 出家させて
もう比丘として修行僧として
育ててあげたりはしていたんですね
ですから 子供のことについては結構
情報はあるんです で 不思議なこと
お寺に入って 例えば子供を大人が育てるようになっても
人間だから情が出てくるということがあるんですね
子供の面倒を見ちゃうと
どうしてもなんとなく情というのは出てくるんですね
それはものすごい厳密に禁止しているんです
情なんかは欲ですから
それはダメだよ お互いに苦しいだけ
子供にしたって 知らない人々に
一生懸命育ててくれると申し訳なくて
申し訳なくて 子供にとってもストレス多いんです
親はもう別にみんなあまり気にしませんけど
他人がね 子供の面倒を一生懸命我が子のように育てると
すごくストレスたまっちゃうんですね
これ アメリカでもよくあります
アメリカではもう平気で子供を養子にするでしょ
それはみんな立派な方々で
全くもう自分の子供のように育てる
大きい文化だから 何のことなく広い文化だからね
それはできます 日本では無理かもしれませんけど
それで子供は知らないんですね
自分が小さい時 赤ちゃんの時
どこから施設からもらった人だということを
でも法律的には18なってくると
子供が聞いたら言わなくちゃいけない
18になってくるともう大人でしょ
だからもう調べると どうせ自分の両親には
もう子供は生まれないということをわかる
簡単に どうせ一緒に生活していたんだから
わかったけど それで私はどうやって
きたということ？問題が出ている
聞いたらもう大体先に気がつくんだけど
両親は言わない 18になったところでもう言わなくちゃいけない
それで言っちゃうでしょうし
言ったら自分の親を探すんですね
元の親を だから育てた親は全く自分の子供だと思っているんだけど
やっぱりその育ての親が全く
もう自分を産んだ親が誰ですかと
父親は誰ですか？探しちゃうんですね
探してどうということはないんだけど
どうせ最初から捨てられちゃったんだから
やっぱりそこら辺理解しないんですね
なぜかというと 一生懸命育てられたんだということがわかったら
ものすごく申し訳なくなっちゃうんですね
自分がわがまま言ったり
喧嘩したり やりたい放題なことをやったり
それは全部こらえて我慢して育てたんだから
悲しい時も もう
一緒に悲しんであげたりとか
いろいろなことをやってくれたんだから
これえらい申し訳ないんですね
それで子供はショックを受けちゃって
自分の本当の親って何なのかと
本当の親だったら こんなに苦しい思いをしないで
済んだんではないかと思っちゃうんですね
だから そういうことっていうのは
育てられた子供にしても
育てた親にしても悲しいんですね
すごい悲しいことになっちゃうんですね
なんでそうなるかというと
そこに情があるからなんです
だから仏教でそれはやってはいけませんと
慈しみでやってくださいと
そうするともうすごい申し訳ない
申し訳ないという もうなんとかということにはならないんですね
お互いにものすごくこの慈しみでありがたいことで
この人間関係は切れないんですね
感謝の気持ちは全く切れないんですね
だから自分が産んだ子供であろうとも
やっぱり人間の一人として育てるんだということを育てると
やっぱりよく育ててくれたんだという感謝が残る
仏教の世界で子供を預かる場合は
必ずもう一人前の人にしてあげるんだ
ということぐらいだけ
考えてやっているんだから
問題は起きません
ほとんどの場合は
そこである経典がありまして
これ大変有名な経典で
仏教は子育て育児論ではなくて
人間論なんですね 人間どのように育てればいいかということで
仏教の育児論というのは
大人になるまで 年取るまで
死ぬまでの話なんです
14歳  18歳に 18歳
20歳になるまでの話じゃないんです
ですから 仏教の育児方法っていうのは
生まれてから死ぬまでのシステムを教える方法なんです
それは全部まとめて教えた経典があります
そちらのポイントだけ一つ一つ申し上げます
全部 1番目 お釈迦様が大事に気をつけて欲しかったのは
悪い人といわゆる頭の悪い人　性格と頭なんですね
性格と頭の悪い人と付き合うなよと
なんででしょうかというと
この子供 赤ちゃんの時からもう
周りを見て子供は習っちゃうんですね
親が変なことをしちゃうと
子供全くやっぱり同じことをやってしまっちゃうしね
親の言葉に訛りがあると
必ずも子供にも訛りが入っちゃうでしょうに
親が乱暴な言葉を使っちゃうと
必ず子供もそういうことを使うでしょ
だから子供っていうのは見て学ぶ
見て学ぶなんですね いわゆるもう真似の専門家なんですね
何でも真似てみる だったら良い人々の環境を作ってあげないと
子供は何真似すればいいんですかね
そこは一番大事なことで
もし自分がたとえ乱暴な人間であろうとも
自分に子供が生まれてきたら
その瞬間から行儀よく
もう正しく生きる人間にならなくちゃいけない
言葉正しく使う もうちゃんと
もうご飯食べる時でも
寝る時でも 何でもきちんとやる人間になればいいんですね
それは自分のためにもなるし
子供のためにもなる 子供がもう真似っこの専門家で
ですから 悪いことは
真似ることできないように
まず環境を作るということ
それは 1番目 ですから
2番目に言っているのは
その同じ言葉の反対 paṇḍitānañca sevanāというパーリ語なんですけど
智慧のある人々と仲良くさせてあげてくださいと
それは子供でも大人でもみんなに同じなんです
子供にでもいろいろ能力ある人々を友達にしてあげる
だから必ずこの同じ年の仲間っていうのはいいわけでもないんですね
いくらか年上のグループに入った方が
子供にとってはいいと思いますけどね
昔 社会だったらやっぱり大きな家族で
村で育てられちゃったんだから
遊び相手っていうのはいつでも
同じ年っていうわけじゃないんですね
時々18歳の男の子が3歳の男の子の
遊び相手になってあげるとかね
ありますからね それ二人ともにもいいことなんですね
18歳の男の子はものすごいもういたずら好きで
乱暴なこと好きな年ですけど
自分と一緒にいるのはちっちゃな子供だったら
すぐ親になっちゃうんですね
面倒を見る あ それはダメだ
これは危険やとかね だから
この大人の子の性格も直せるし
子供にしてもよくいろんなことを教えてくれる友達だから
もうすごくいいことなんですね
例えば同じ年の仲間だったら
もう勉強すること何一つもない
それも必要なんですけど
paṇḍitānañca sevanāっていう
やっぱり頭のいい人々の仲間を作ってあげてくださいと
だからとにかくもう頭の良いことですね
いわゆる道徳判断をちゃんとできる
判断能力ある人間になることはすごく大事なことなんです
頭のいいっていうことは
もう皆様思っているような
学校に行って勉強できるという
そんなくだらんことではないんです
どんなバカな人にも勉強ぐらいはできますからね
それは頭のいいっていうことじゃないんで
やっぱり判断能力ある
特に道徳の世界で良いこと悪いこと
きちんと論理的に判断能力があるっていうことは
すごい頭のいいことなんですね
それから3番目に言ったのは
敬うこと　敬うことに値するべき人々を
敬うことを習うことですね
だからいきなりみんな平等だ平等だとかね
それはちょっと子育てには危ないんですね
例えばもう日本でよく見られることで
いつでもお母さんが子供に謝るんですね
あ ごめんごめんとかね
そんなことをずっとやっちゃうと
えらい性格が悪くなるんですね
私 実際にそういう一つのケースは知ってます
親に向かって子供が謝れと怒鳴りつける
私が見たら 別に親が謝るぐらいのこと何もやってないし
子供が悪いことしているのに理解していないんですね
自分が悪いと 好き勝手にわがままで親が悪いんだと
自分のわがままを聞いてくれなかったんだと
それでなんでそういうことになったかというと
この変な西洋的な思考で
みんな平等やと思って
平等じゃないんです 子育ての場合は
ですから 私たち死ぬまで
やっぱり尊敬するべき人々が
我々の社会にいっぱいいるんですね
頭下げなくちゃいけない
話を聞いていただかなくちゃいかない
指導してもらわなくちゃいけない
そういう人間っていうのはいつでもいるんですね
もし私が世界一頭の良い人で
世界一できた人間であるならば
誰もいませんけどね
それはありえないことでしょうに
それは絶対ありえないんです
人間というのは完璧になれないし
例えば 何て言いますか
ノーベル賞をもらうかもしれませんけど
日本の一人の方がノーベル賞をもらったんだからって
この方がすべてのことを知っているわけじゃないでしょ
ある一つのことは もうノーベル賞をもらうところまでできているんであって
まだ知らないことはいっぱいありますね
世の中で それはその都度その都度
その人が教えてもらわなくちゃいけない
ですから たとえノーベル賞をもらうぐらいの
能力のある知識人であろうとも
敬うべき人々を敬う性格ないと
それは小さいとき教えてあげないと
えらい気持ち悪い 頑固な役に立たない人間になるんですね
ですから ある これスリランカの子供なんですけど
日本に来て会って話したんだところなんですけど
仏教では親に礼しなくちゃいけないんですね
仏法僧に礼をすることと全く同じ形で
皆様はこの仏像の前でお寺に
どんなお寺に行ってもちゃんと手を合わせて礼拝するでしょ？で
我々の仏教になると お釈迦様の前で
仏法僧の前でお寺に行って礼拝することだけじゃなくて
自分の両親にも同じくやらなくちゃいけないんです
むこうはもう全く平気でやってますけどね
だからスリランカの家族でしたから
スリランカの文化によって日本の文化は違いますけど
文化で子供に両親にもちゃんと礼をしなさいということを
教えなくちゃいけなくなっちゃったんですね
おじいちゃんおばあちゃんなんか
誰か誰かいるんだったら
それは何のことなく教えられる
まねっこだから なぜかというと
自分のお父さんがおじいさまにものすごく礼をする
自分のお母さんも頭を下げて礼をする
それ見ると子供まねっこだから
やっぱりおじいさんおばあさんに礼をするでしょ
その瞬間でおじいさんおばあさんが
じゃあお父さんにもお母さんにもちゃんとやってちょうだいと言うんですね
それで子供たちと これ楽しい仕事で
何のことなく身についてしまっちゃうんですね
これでもう夫婦だけで子供連れて日本に来てしまったところで
これもう教えてあげなくちゃいけない年になったら
これを教えなくちゃいけない
できない なぜならば ちゃんと自分に礼をしなさいと言えませんから
いくらなんでも 一応言ったところで
子供がそれを訳聞いたんですね
なんで人間なのにみんな礼をしなくちゃ
いけないんですかと聞いちゃったら
もうその夫婦もいい加減な夫婦で
仏教ぐらいちょっと勉強しておけばね
答えられるのに答えられなくて
子供はこういう風に言うんだけど
困ったもんだと 何も言えないんだと
でもしきたりやらね 習慣ということもやっぱり勉強した方がいいんじゃないかなと思いますけど
そういう問題をとにかく起きたんですね
ですから 小さい時から
我々は子供っていうのはまねっこだから
やっぱり目上の人々を敬うように
尊敬するように この価値観を入れてあげる
それで子供はなんで？と聞いたら
はっきり教えればいいんです
ちゃんと先生に礼をしなさい
なんでと だってお前何も知らんでしょうに
これから先生が全部教えてあげるでしょうに
だから礼をしなきゃいけませんと
礼をしたら あんたは立派な人間だと
よくできた子だと 先生はあなたのことをすごくかわいがってくれるんだと
そうすると親切に教えてくれるんだと
なんかヘマでもやっても
先生はまあいいやと言って
それは何とかしてあげるんだと
何でおじいちゃんに礼をしなくちゃ
だっておじいちゃんというのは
もう私たちを育ててくれたのおじいさんでしょうに
ご飯食べさせたり 面倒見てくれたりしたのおじいさんだから
君たちもいないでしょうと
だからもうちゃんと礼をしなさいと
そうやって尊敬に値するべき人々に
尊敬できるような性格を育てる
なぜ お釈迦様が尊敬に値するという
形容詞を使ったかというと
ただ目上の人を敬いなさいという風な
このフラットで言わないんですね
たとえ年上であろうとも
だらしない人間 犯罪者とかね
そんな礼をする必要はないんです
やっぱりその場合は やっぱりこの人の生き方が良くないんだと
人間にとっては迷惑だと
この人の生き方が それは子供も理解するでしょう
だから自分も礼をしなくたってもいいんだと
それさえも良い教育なんですね
やっぱり人間としては道徳正しい立派な
人間にいなくちゃいけないということ
ですから お釈迦様はわざとこの尊敬に値する人々に尊敬するようにと
その習慣つけてあげてくださいと
次に出てくるのは 環境
良い環境を選んでくださいと
それは大人にも子供にも同じなんですね
立派な人間として育てやすい
生活しやすい 環境を選ばなくちゃいけない
例えば 黄金三角地帯ありますね
ミャンマーやらタイやら
ラオスやら そこら辺の全部境界線ばっかりあるところで
ゴールデントライアングルというところがあるんですね
だから どんな国から見てもものすごい遠い田舎なんですね
だから政治的な力も全然入らない
全く田舎であって 隣の国の境界線でありますからね
放っておくんですね
そこら辺は それで その人々にとってはもう政治家もいないし
警察も来ないし もう好き勝手に生きていられる
でも誰も面倒見てくれない
それでもうこの人々が麻薬
売買しましょう 売買じゃない
何て言いますか 作るんですね
作って作って それは製造してもう売ったりする
だからどんな人でもやっぱり麻薬のその畑作ってるんですね
誰も悪いと思ってないんですね
なぜかというと それでちゃんと 1日の給料をいただくんだから
それで食べているんだから
それでアメリカが怒っても
アメリカが自分の国に麻薬が
入らないように法律を作らないで
三角地帯 その国々に文句を言うんですね
あんた方は作るなよと
そんないい加減なことを言ったとしても
その人々にとっては他の生きる方法はないんですね
米は作れないし 教育もないし
学校もないし それでもし日本の誰かが
土地が安いんだからといって
そこら辺の土地を買ってしまえばどうなるかというと
そちらは教育システムもない
警察もいない もう麻薬売買人に支配されていて
政治はそちらがやっていて
日本の家族をそちらに行ったら
その人言う通りにやらなくちゃいけなくなっちゃうんです
あんたが威張るんじゃなくて
この工場ぐらい手伝ってくださいと
もっと品質の 日本人だからね
もっと品質の高い 純度が高い麻薬を作るように頑張りなさい
そうでなきゃ殺してやるぞと言っちゃったらどうしますかね
やらなくちゃいけないことになりますね
ですから 環境を選ぶということは
とても大事なことなんです
たとえ自分が生まれた田舎であろうとも
子育てに 自分の人生にうまく適応してない場合は
その場所を離れるんだと
だからお釈迦様は私の土地
代々通して伝わってくる土地とか
そういうくだらない価値観を入れてないんです
土地は捨てていくものであって
人間で生まれた時から死ぬまで立派に
生きているかということはもっと大事だよと
仏教から見れば 国捨てたってもどうってことないんです
それはすごい寂しいんですけど
それでも自分にとっては
自分の家族にとっては良いことがなければ
もう国でも捨てちゃったとしても
それはどうってことない
なぜならば 人間生きることはもっと大事なんです
人間が幸せに生きることは
変な名前を付けている国の名前よりも大事なんです
いい加減にあちこち境界線を作ったりしてね
お互いに喧嘩したり 殺し合いやったりする
バカなことでしょう ただの土地のために殺し合いやっていて
そういうのはバカバカしいし
だからもうどこでも人間っていうのは
死ぬまで幸せで豊かで道徳の人間で生きてほしいんだから
場所を選べと それ 4番目の決まりなんです
子供にとっても同じこと
子供にすごい立派に教育してあげたければ
それなりの環境 教育のある場所を選ばなくちゃいけない
子供にいろんな技術を身につけてほしいければ
そういう場所を選ばなくちゃいけない
子供は立派な
バレリーナにしたければ
ソ連にでも行かなくちゃいけないんだから
しょうがないんです
そこで次にあるのは
過去で良いことがしたことがあるという項目なんです
これ すごい意味取りにくい言葉なんですね
いわゆる過去で徳を積んだことがあること
これどういうことですかね
この徳を積んだということは
自分が悪いことをしていないということなんです
恥じることは何一つもやっていないんだと
隠すことは何もないんだ
自分の人生で だから小さい時からもう恥じること
バレたらまずいこと
知られたらもう大変になることっていうのは
一つもやらないように気をつける
そうすると どこにいたとしても大丈夫なんです
例えば 私は自分の国で犯罪を起こしたとします
犯罪を起こしちゃったりして
もう日本に逃げている
日本で犯罪を起こしていないんだから
堂々と胸を張って喋ったりする
でも もしそれはバレちゃったら
日本の法律では何の問題もないんだけど
やっぱりみんなの前で堂々と喋ることもできないし
この国で幸せで生きることもできなくなるでしょうに
大体よく国際的な犯罪を起こす人々っていうのは
すぐ国を逃げちゃうんですね
逃げてどこかで隠れて偉そうにそこでも生活するんだけど
結局そちらでもやるのは犯罪ですけどね
だから結局自由に生きていられないんですね
国から逃げても 日本で殺人を犯して
もうアメリカやらフランスどこかで逃げているんだと言ったっても
生活は自由じゃないんですね
幸せじゃないんですね
だから赤軍の人々やらね
日本の政府はいまだにもう追っているんだから
返せ返せと たとえもう中東の方やらね
もう北朝鮮の方でいても
あれで立派な生活をしているんだということを言えますかね
やっぱり過去でいいことをしたことがないんだから
人生不幸になる ですから
人間っていうのはすっごく気をつけて
バレたらまずいこと 知られたらまずいこと
全くしないように気をつけて生活するということは
これは大事だよと これは子供の人生から大人まで大事な生き方なんですね
次のポイントはAttasammāpaṇidhiという言葉で
自分の自己管理ですね
正しく自己管理をできる人間になる
いわゆる感情に 今の子供たちみたいにちょっとしたことでもカッとなるとかね
あれ病気なんですけどね
食べ物のせいだと思いますけどね
いきなりものすごくカッとなって自分を見失うんですね
何するかわからなくなっちゃう
時々みんなストレス溜まって
人を誰でもいいんだから人を殺したくなったぞとかね
そりいい加減でしょ 自分にストレス溜まったんだからといって
誰でも人を殺してしまっちゃうんですね
公園なんかに人が寝ていたら行ってぶん殴って殺しちゃう
オヤジ狩りとか言葉まで作ったりして
仕事をして 苦労して苦労で疲れて
やっと家に帰る この男性の人々は狙って殴ったり蹴ったりする
やりたい放題 向こうももう喧嘩できないし
もう疲れてるんだから
相手が若者だから力もあるでしょうに
またグループで来るんだからね
みんな間抜けないんだから
一人では喧嘩しない グループを組んで喧嘩するでしょ
喧嘩だったら堂々と一対一でやればね
立派ですけど それもできない
間抜けない グループを組んで人を殺したりする
ですから やっぱりこのすぐカッとなったりするし
感情はコントロールできない
性格は良くない ですから
自己管理できるように
小さい時からも我々は子供に教えてあげる
大人になって我々今からでも自己管理できる
人間になるということは必要なんですね
次にお釈迦様がおっしゃるポイントは
bāhusaccañ ca sippañ caということ
それはよく勉強しなさいよと
いろんな技術を学んでくださいと
人間というのは勉強と技術でなければ生きていられないんです
犬猫と違いますからね
犬猫にしたとしても それなりの技術は身についてますけど
だから勉強嫌だ 嫌いだ
じゃあ嫌だったらやめましょうとかね
そういうのはそんな甘えすぎですね
だからもう人間 言葉を使ってる
言葉でも勉強しなくちゃいけないですね
文字使ってるので それ勉強しなくちゃあかんでしょうに
わがままはできません
だからもう人間であるならば
我々はずっといろんなことを勉強しなくちゃいけない
小さい時から当たり前で
大人になっても新しいことを
勉強していかなくちゃいけないんです
それはものすごい楽しいことで
年取ったんだからやめたと言ったら暗いでしょうに
年取ってもいいんですよ
新しいことにチャレンジする
英語の勉強でもやってみる
コンピューターでもいじってみるとかね
今の年になって あんた何やってるかということよりも
やっぱり時間無駄に使わないで
何か新しいことを勉強するという
それから新しいいろんな技術をね
何かいつでも知っておく
いつでも知っておく だからもう会社にしたとしても
みんな時代遅れになっちゃうんですね
どんどんと時間経つと技術は改良するわ
もう会社のシステムが変わるわ
それで45歳ぐらいの歳の人々はもう追いつけなくなって
どんどん後ろに下がっちゃうでしょうに
そうすると若者に追い越されちゃうし
自分の仕事は危うい状態になってしまっちゃうし
だから仏教は時代遅れになることはあまり認めない
いつでも時代の先端にいなくちゃいけないんですね
何が変わっても それはすごい簡単です
すごく面白く世の中を見ていると
まあどうってことない
明日理解できないほど世界が発展するかというと
それは絶対ありえないでしょうに
今日の延長線の明日でしょうに
だから明日のことは理解できます
そういうことだから 死ぬまで世界はどう変わっても
もう対応できます ですから
そのポイント 勉強しなさいということ
勉強と同時に次に必要な
vinayo ca susikkhito　道徳
自己管理できるって前言ったんだけど
ちょっと似ているような感じもしますけど
道徳を勉強しなさいと
いわゆる嘘をついてはいけないとかね
人のものを取ってはいけないとか
約束を守らなきゃダメですよとかね
そういういろいろ道徳あるでしょうに
ちゃんと勉強だけではダメでしょうし
ちゃんと道徳を持っていること
それは子供にしても
大人にしても同じことなんです
次のポイントは
subhāsitā ca yā vācāということで
美しい言葉を語れと
いわゆる語る者が洗練したものを語ってくださいと
感情でぺちゃぺちゃしゃべるのは
仏教ではあまり認めない
しゃべるものは 聞く人にも理解できるようにちゃんと管理して
考えた上でしっかりした言葉でしっかりした発音で喋ってほしい
それは大変なことで この人間の文化っていうのは
もう言葉の文化であって
もうえらいことでしょうに
ちょっと舌が滑っちゃったらもう大変なことになるでしょ
日本はもうなんか誰かなんか言っちゃってね
なんか神の国やなんとか言っちゃって大変なことになったでしょうに
だからそんないい加減に言葉をしゃべるということを
気をつけた方がいいんですね
本人が別にどうったかなんも思わないで
日本は神の国だからとか
なんとか言ったかもしれませんけど
でもそれはちゃんと客観的に見てみると
もう大変な問題を受けてしまう
ですから 人間というのは
言葉っていうのはすべての災いの元
だから一切の苦しみの元
戦争の元 ですから 言葉だけは気をつけてほしい
言葉だけではなくて 言葉にはとことん気をつける
時々子供は親の言うことをなぜ聞かないかというと
親がしゃべるわ
しゃべるわ
きりがなくしゃべる だから子供から見ればどうせうるさいんだから
同じことを48回ぐらい言うんだからと
だから1回聞いて47回もう聞かなくてもいいや
ということになるでしょう
だから 聞く耳は持てなくなっちゃうんですね
大事なことしか言わない場合は
何か喋ったら気をつけて聞く
だから子育ての場合も結構失敗あるのは
よくしゃべる みんな遊びで喋ってるんだったらいいんだけど
これもうこのしつけなんですね
だから 耳に入らなくなっちゃう
ですから 言葉の管理大変大事です
そういうことはもう子供の時から習うところで
それで人がどんどん18歳ぐらいになってくる
20歳ぐらいになってくるでしょ
そんな生き方やっていると
環境も選んで 教育も受けて
技術も身について 言葉の管理もできて
道徳も知っていて 自己管理もできて
良い仲間もいて 敬う目上の人々を敬う人間になったところで
もう20歳ぐらいの立派な大人になってくるんですね
それで次の仕事があるんです
mātāpitu-upattānam
自分の両親の面倒を見なさいと
自分が一人前になってくると
両親がもうどんどん中年になってくるんですね
そこから両親から今まで散々
お世話になってもらったんだから
これからもうお返しの時間ですね
ですから 必ず両親の面倒を見ること
だから その年によって変わります
両親がすごく病気になって倒れちゃったら
それはそれなりに看病する
ただ中年ぐらいになってきたら
それなりに両親のことを面倒見ればいいんです
とにかくこの状況を判断しながら
両親のことは一生忘れないで
感謝の気持ちでやってあげることは
何一つも欠けることなくやってあげると
それは人間として大事な仕事なんです
私は忙しいんだからといってとんでもない話なんです
忙しいことはそんなにえらいことでもなんでもないんです
あなたを作ったのはこの二人だから
あなたの人生を幸せになるためには
両親の面倒を見なくちゃいけないんです
それで生きる喜びを感じるんです
後で悔しくなるだけでね
父親が倒れちゃったんだけど
看病にはお見舞いには一度も行けなかったんだとかね
ある人が最近言ったんですよ
私に 父親が死んじゃったんだけど
お葬式にも行かなかったんだと
半年か3ヶ月とか後で電話したら
見せてみたら 父親は亡くなって全部終わったんだよと
もう家から言ってくれたんだと
本人がえらいことをやっているような感じで言うんで
私はものすごく怒鳴ったんですね
そこでまた仏教の人だから
だから会って話すことになりましたからね
あんた偉そうに仏教ぶってるんだけど
人間にもなってないんだと
基本的な人間にもなってないんだと
何ですか それは威張ることかと
たとえ何があっても 父親がね
そうやって倒れちゃったらね
行ってそばにいてあげるということは
やってあげる人にもすごい生きる喜びを感じられるし
父親にしたとしても ものすごい良い気持ちで
死にかけている人々にとっては
自分の子供たちが周りにいることほど
ありがたいことはないんですよ
ですから 親の面倒を見ること
それからputtadārassa saṅgaho もう結婚適齢になってくるんだからね
相手と子供たちの面倒を見なさいということでね
それは大体当たり前のことで
それでちょっと日本で感じたことがありますけど
なんか時々なんか奥さんのことをあまり
大事にしない人々を私は知ってるんですね
なんかもう自分の父親の
お母さんの面倒を見る
それはあなたの仕事ではないかと
奴隷買ったと思ってるんですかね
自分が全く別な家から人をもらったんだから
その人のことをものすごく
大事にしなくちゃいけないんですね
それは自分の両親の面倒を見たならば
それはすごくありがたいことやと
あんたは本当に申し訳ない
よくやってくれたんだと
私のお父さんの面倒をよく見てくれたんだと
それぐらい気持ちがないと
幸せでは生きていられませんね
そういうことで自分の奥さんやら子供たちの
面倒を見るという仕事が次に出てくる
で それからanavajjāni kammāniという言葉がありまして
罪を犯さないこと
仕事とかいろんなことをやるでしょうに
ですから その時でもやっぱりもう間違った仕事とかしないで
ちゃんとした生き方をすることになっています
それからārati virati pāpāという
それも同じ意味で罪を犯さない
やっぱりもう酒に溺れたり
悪いことをしたり もう邪な行為をしたりとかね
お金が入るとすぐそこに行くんですね
家に帰るんじゃなくて
パブに行くんでしょうに
お金があるんだからといって
それで結局人生は台無しになりますけどね
だからこれはもう絶対いかんということではなくて
その社会によって生き方が違いますからね
やっぱり家は大事ということは覚えておいて
罪を犯さないことを気をつけた方がいいんですね
それで仏教だからね 酒は飲まないと
これはもう人間バカになっちゃうんですね
どうなるかわからなくなっちゃうんですね
酒っていうのはえらい
もう何て言いますか 魔の薬で
麻薬といったらちょっと意味が違いますからね
で魔が言われる通りに何でもやるように
なってしまっちゃうんですね
ですから これはもう酒はやめた方がいいし
大人になってからの話で
それからこのもう 例えばもう若さもどんどんいってしまうでしょうね
例えば35ぐらいになってくると
40ぐらい近寄ってくると
もう徹底した大人でしょうに
もう責任持ってる時代でしょうに
その時はすごく謙虚であること
威張らないことですね
ものすごく謙虚であること
それから落ち着いていること
よく見えますね この40代の人々
全然落ち着いてない すごくストレスかかっちゃうんですね
それにだから一番バリバリ仕事をする時になってくると
いつでも謙虚で それからいつでも落ち着いていることを習う
次に大事な言葉 santutthīという言葉があります
それは自分が得たもので十分満足する
いわゆるキリがなく 欲を抱いてはいけません
もう自分の将来が見えているんだからね
この会社だったら 係長まででもやっとだとわかったら
そこら辺で覚悟を決めて
課長まではとにかくと思ったら
もうクビになるかもしれません
課長になるどころか リストラの時代だから
そうすると人生が楽しめなくなっちゃうんですね
もう自分の能力も知られてるでしょ
40飛んじゃうと 40になってくると
それで私の人生に能力はここら辺だよと思って
この満足する性格 それはsantutthīと書くんだけど
直訳は喜びなんですね
喜びを感じなさいよということなんです
それでもう家を作れるぐらい収入ないんだったら
それでもバカでかい家
家を作りたいとかね
えらいもう欲出しちゃうと喜べないんですね
生きることは 一生アパート暮らしでも
自分の能力はもう知られたところで
それは喜べばいいんです
ですから 喜びを感じなさいということ
で 次に これはお釈迦様の話だから
時期を見てちゃんと法を聞きなさいと
仏教を勉強しなさいということなんです
仏教というのは 世の中のすべての真理をまとめて教えているんですね
生命って何なのか 何のために生きているんですか？何をするべきかとかね
心の働きとか ありったけのことを全部教えているんですから
人間バカで死んでほしくないんですね
今まではお釈迦様は仕事に必要なことだけ教えたんです
ここでもう仕事も安定してあって
そろそろ退職するんである時期だからね
じゃあもう真理にチャレンジしなさいと
ですから 法を聞くこと入ってるんですね
それからtapo ca brahmacariyañ ca
例えばもう人が例えば仕事を終わった
まあ65 70歳にもなりましたとする
それでもパブばっかしに
飲み屋さんばっかし歩き回ったり
若い娘さんの体触ったりいじったりとかね
そればっかしやっちゃうと
全くみっともない人間でしょうね
家の奥さんがもう年だから
もうババアだからといって
いろいろ若い女の子がもう人を騙して
酒を売っているところにいて
そこで遊んだりすると
もう最悪状態になるんですね
人生は不幸に もうものすごく不幸になるんです
そこでお釈迦様が言うのは
一旦年取ってきたら
欲を捨てて もうtapo修行でもちょっとやってみる
brahmacariyaっていうのはもう欲をやめることなんですね
異性に対する欲をね もうやめる
もう関係ないと綺麗に頭からそこら辺消しておく
大体医学的なこと言って
男だったら80歳になっても90歳になっても
もういくらでも異性との関係もてるぞとか
何とか言うんだけど
そんな変な屁理屈で やっぱり年取ってくれば
もう体力っていうのは守った方がいいんですね
だから 性的なことに絞る体力は
自分の健康のために ボケないために
トラブルを起こさないために使った方がいいんですね
女の子もやっぱり恐ろしいことで
このおじいちゃんにお金あるんだなとわかったら
もうものすごく褒めるんですね
やっぱり私は若い人は嫌いだとかね
あいつらバカだとかね おじいちゃんの方がすごく大好きですよとか
だから結婚しようと 今度財産狙っちゃうんですね
で 結婚しちゃったら早く殺しちゃうし
そういうのは世の中で大体はあるんですからね
やっぱり年取ってくると欲をやめた方が
自分のためになるということ
それからお釈迦様がおっしゃった存在の真理があるんです
苦集滅道という その真理を体験できるように頑張ってみなさいと
仕事はあるんです 例えば
異性との遊ぶことをやめたんだからといって
つまらないわけじゃないんです
すごい仕事はあるんです
真理を発見するために頑張ってくださいと
それからnibbānasacchikiriyā ca
涅槃を体験しなさいと
解脱を体験しなさいと
それは在家の方々にもできます
こちら出家しなさいと書いてないんです
涅槃というのは心の安らぎだから
もう苦集滅道というお釈迦様の真理を発見して
滅という涅槃ですね それは自分の心でも体験できるように頑張ってみる
もし自分が正しく子供育てたならば
子供は自分の面倒を見てくれる
ご飯ぐらいは作ってくれる
それで自分がもう真理に目指して頑張っちゃえば
それで涅槃さえも獲得できると
それでもうすべて終わりですよ
プログラムは人生の だからお釈迦様の育児っていうのは
この子供育てだけじゃなくて
死ぬまでのプログラム
死ぬ時は涅槃まで 解脱まで自分のものにして死ぬ
それ人生はすべて成功したことになります
それで次にお釈迦様はどうやって
自分が一人前の立派な人間になったかと
あなた知ってますかと
その問題が出てきますね
その問題 次に答えるんですね
phuṭṭhassa lokadhammehi cittaṃ yassa na kampati
もし世の中で損があるわ
得があるわ 家も火事になるわ
時々すごい儲かったりするわ
いろんなことあるでしょうに
家の連中は病気になっちゃうわ
時々すごい元気になって行動するしね
批判されつつ 褒められるし
世の中っていうのは波が多い
落ち着いてる自分が世の中のどんな波が起きても
自分は落ち着いていられるならば
あまり気にしないという状態でいられるならば
悲しみが心にないならば
何も悲しいことはない
心配することなんもない
もう時々経済状態悪くなったって
まあまあ そんな世の中だからといって落ち着いている
自分の子供たち 孫たちはバンバン儲かるようになっちゃったら
今はなんか経済状態いいみたいですよって
あんまりそこでもって喜んで
舞い上がったりもしないという
落ち着いていられるならばということ
それでasokaṃ 困ること
悩むこと何もない virajaṃ
もう心にあまり欲もない
これやりたい あれやりたいと欲もない
それからすごく安定感がある
khemaṃ 平和がある 心の中で
それはもう人間が成功した証拠なんです
あ この人はもう人生は成功しているんだと
年取ったところであんまり世の中のことを
気にしないで落ち着いている
そこでお釈迦様は最後に結論するんですね
etādisāni katvāna
あなた方はこのように生きているんだったら
sabbattha-m-aparājitā
どこででも負けませんと
どんなことにおいても勝利者になるんだと
sabbattha sotthiṃ gacchanti
人生のいかなるところにおいても成功するんだと
これこそ生きる道だよと
という風にお釈迦様はその経典進めちゃうんですね
だから仏教の育児方法っていうのは
そういうかなりスケールの大きい死ぬまでの教育なんです
そこで話は終了したいんですが
またいっぱい情報は持ってますけど
親に対して  6つのことを考えなくてはいけないんですね
1番目は親に育てられたので親を養います
1 これ子供の責任 親はもう年取っちゃったんだから
親の仕事やら親がやらなくちゃいけないことを
自分がバトンタッチしてやってあげますと
2番目 そこで親の家柄
親の家の習慣 しきたり
そういうものはやっぱり子供が続けてほしい
という希望が親にあるんですね
ですから 自分の家のしきたり
習慣やら そういうものを守ってあげますと
それから もし親に財産があって
自分にその財産が自分のものになったならば
それは親も安心できるように
親も喜べるように ちゃんと財産を
無駄にしないで ちゃんと財産を管理して商売もするんだと
だから親からもらった財産はもっとよく
しっかりするようにしてあげるという責任
それから親が死んでから親に供養してあげたと
それは子供の責任 6つです
それで親の責任はまた6つあります
まず道徳を教えること
pāpā nivāretiって書いてますけど
罪から罪を犯さないような人間にしてあげる
何があっても悪いことだけはできない人間に育ててあげること
それから いつでも良いこと
人を助けてあげることやら
人に親切にしてあげることやら
そうやって善行為をできる人間にしてあげる
3番目sippaṃ sikkhāpenti教育させる
見てください この順番
お釈迦様は最初に人間育てること
教育は 3番目に来るんです
それで 4番目は子供にふさわしい相手を
見つけてあげてくださいということ
これは今の時代ではあまり
関係ないかもしれませんけど
やっぱり自分の子供の性格
生き方は親は一番よく知ってますね
それで親同士で話し合って
ふさわしい人を選んであげるんだったら
やっぱり大変いいことですけど
やっぱり今の時代からこれ計算して言うならば
やっぱり親にも納得できる相手と
結婚した方がいいということなんですね
親はあまり反対しない人と
結婚した方がすごくうまくいくんですね
それはできた親の場合です
できてない親の反対はあまり当てになりませんからね
もし仏教的に子供を育てた親だったら
もう親が賛成する人と結婚した方がぴったし合うんです
自分で選んでも 親に聞いてみたら
この人どうですかと それは5番目
6番目 自分の財産を商売でも店でも会社でも
自分のものあるならば
もう息子にはい どうぞやってくださいと
で 自分が引退する その 6つは親の役目で
前の 6つは子供の役目で
そういう風にやってくださいというのは
また一つのお釈迦様の教えなんです
そこで それで話は終わります
それからちょっとした遊びでもう一つ言います
お釈迦様に息子がいたんですよ
でもお釈迦様はこの息子を出家させたんですね
出家させたんだから これ息子は王子様でしたから
出家でえらい苦労をしただろうと思います
食べるものもなくて 面倒を見る家来もなくて
7歳でしたから 家来もいないし
美味しいものを食べることもできないし
お世話は一人も誰もいない
その時自分の息子をね
やっぱりそれを出家させて
でお釈迦様はやっぱりお釈迦様だから
自分の子供は特別扱いしちゃうと
これまた他の人間にとっては良くないんですね
みんなの面倒見るんだから
お釈迦様 みんなの父親でしたから
だから我が子なんですけど
特別扱いすることもできない
サンガの一員として育てたんだから
そこでよくわかるんですね
お釈迦様が自分の我が子ということではなくて
あなたはもう出家したんだ
だから このサンガという大きなコミュニティの一員だけですよと
特別扱いないんだとその態度でお釈迦様は
やっぱり息子のことを心配するんですね
それが親の仕事 息子が一員として頑張れるかと
特別扱いなし 一員として頑張ってくれるんだったら
お釈迦様も安心だということで
ある日自分の息子に会ったんです
こそこそと 公では会わないんです
そこでお釈迦様と息子のラーフラ尊者の間で
対話があったんですね
それはどれほど美しいお釈迦様の言葉かというと
私は何回読んでも涙が出るんです
それぐらいすごいもう美しい父親のあるべき姿と
息子のあるべき姿が見える偈なんですね
残念ながら皆様にはパーリ語はわかりませんので
その味は味わえないと思いますけどね
こんな大人になっている私はもう
何を見たって読んでも全然感動しない
とんでもないつまらない人間なんですけど
この経典のこれ読むとやっぱり
感動するんですね お釈迦様はラーフラ尊者にこう聞くんですね
Kacci abhiṇhasaṃvāsā nāvajānāsi paṇḍitaṃ
Ukkādhāro manussānaṃ kacci apacito tayā
君どうですか？と ずっと仲良く付き合っているんだからと思って
賢者のことを馬鹿にすることでもしますかと
賢者っていうのは目上の人々ですね
ずっと一緒にいるんだからといって
目上の人々のことを馬鹿にすることでもしますか？と
軽視することでもしますかと
Ukkādhāro manussānaṃ kacci apacito tayā
人間にあの灯火を持っている人を尊敬していますかと
いわゆる人間 人類に知恵の灯
知恵の光のように見せている方を
あなた尊敬していますか？と
それは誰のことかというと
お釈迦様は自分の子供にはやっぱり
良い環境を作ってあげなくちゃいけないんだと
良いお友達を作ってあげなくちゃいけないと思って
知恵の第一人者であったサーリプッタ尊者に任せたんです
この子供のことをよろしくお願いしますと
それっきりお釈迦様は面倒見なかったんです
だからやっぱり父親なんですよ
子供に教育させるために人を選ぶ場合は
もう人類の知恵の第一人者は自分の弟子だから
その人に任せたんですね
サーリプッタ尊者っていうのは
もう尊者っていうのはもう人間の中の人間で
頭はものすごく良かったんだけど
すっごい謙虚な方なんですね
だから子供っていうのは
ちょっとからかったり
馬鹿にしたりする可能性はいくらでもあります
だから 私も時々そういう問題あるんだけど
やっぱり若者とか子供と付き合っている場合は
いつでもガリガリで頑固でできませんし
いつでも知恵ばっかり見せびらかしちゃうと
子供にはやりきれないんですよ
だからたまたま何か言うんだけど
それからみんなと一緒にふざけて遊んだりする
それで時々子供は勘違いするんですね
自分と同じ仲間やと 勘違いして
もうこちらは大事な仕事をしている時でも走ってきて
一緒に遊ぼうとかね
それはちょっと困っちゃうんですね
もう説法をしている時でも来て
手を引っ張ったりとかしたりする場合もあったんだから
やっぱり子供っていうのはそういう性格もありますから
しょうがないんだけど
お釈迦様はそこは気をつけるんですね
あなたは人類に灯火を持っている人を
ちゃんと尊敬していますかと
そこでラーフラ尊者がそう答えるんですね
Nāhaṃ abhiṇhasaṃvāsā avajānāmi paṇḍitaṃ
長い間一緒に生活するんだからといって
私は目上の人は決して貶すこと
軽視することを決してしませんと
Ukkādhāro manussānaṃ niccaṃ apacito mayā
人類に知恵の灯火を持っている人は
私は永遠に尊敬しているんだと
その行だけ覚えておいて
それはすごい この仏教の中であるすごい立派な言葉なんです
Ukkādhāro manussānaṃ
この行なんですけど ukkādhāroっていうのは
この光を持っている人
manussānaṃ 人類に灯火ですね
人類に灯火を持ってる人
niccaṃ常にいつでも
apacito私は尊敬しています
mayā 私はですね
で 英語では I always respect the torchbearer of mankind.
それすっごい立派な言葉なんです 我々は誰を尊敬するべきかというと
人類に知恵の光を与えている
人々を永遠に尊敬するべきですね
申し訳ないですけど もう一回ゆっくりちょっと説明
Ukkādhāro manussānaṃ niccaṃ apacito mayā
誰かカタカナで書いていただけませんか
あの灯火を持つ人類に灯火を持つ人が
私に常に尊敬されていますというふうには
ちゃんとした直訳なんです
パッシブボイスで言ってるんです
それもものすごい相手のことを尊敬すると
日本でもこの受動詞使ってますね
パーリ語でも同じことで
ですから私はあの人のことを
尊敬してませんってことじゃなくて
私に尊敬されてますと
もっと敬語なんです
一応仏教の育児論というのは
もうちょっとスケール大きいんだから
ちょっと把握できなかったかもしれませんけど
とにかくわかっているところで頑張ってください
どうもありがとうございました